Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat entschieden, dass die Vereine der DFL an Mehrkosten für Polizeieinsätze bei Hochrisikospielen beteiligt werden sollen. Ihr habt es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber vielleicht habt ihr euch auch gefragt, was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich und wie ist es dazu gekommen? Diese Fragen und noch weitere werden wir jetzt hier besprechen. Und ich habe dafür eine tolle Runde hier. Philipp Maume und Fabian Reinholz. Ich stelle sie euch gleich vor. Jetzt geht's los hier im Rasenfunk. Ertes Publikum, der Rasenfunk.
Bei diesen Risikospielen da kommen dann Hooligans. Und die wollen sich einfach prügeln, die wollen in die möglicherweise Innenstädte in Schutt und Asche legen.
Gerade wenn auch manche etwas schwierigen Fußball-Kaoten aus Ostdeutschland beispielsweise bei Spielen in Bayern anreisen, ein Mindest so großen Polizeiansatz wie bei einem großen Spiel des FC Bayern.
Meine Erwartungshaltung ist schon die, dass wir die Veranstalterrolle in den Blick nehmen und dass wir das Verursacherprinzip in den Blick nehmen, denn es bleibt doch festzuhalten, dass die DFL mindestens eine Co-Veranstalterrolle hat.
Allein über die drei O-Töne. In diesem Intro könnte man schon eine Stunde diskutieren. Und deswegen hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr, hier juristische Fachkompetenz an meiner Seite zu haben. Unter anderem vertreten durch Philipp Maume. Er ist Professor an der TU München und hatte auch schon vor vielen, vielen Jahren einen Kontakt zu unserem anderen Gast. Können wir vielleicht gleich noch auflösen. Philipp, schön, dass du hier im Rasenfunk bist.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass das geklappt hat.
Was ist denn dein Bezug zu Sportrecht? Denn wir haben uns schon vor der Sendung darüber ausgetauscht. Es ist gar nicht so üblich, das als Hauptberuf zu haben.
Nee, also an der Uni eigentlich nicht, denn auf Sportrecht kann man nicht so wirklich eine Karriere bauen. Das baut man eher so auf die klassischen juristischen Bereiche. Aber es gibt auch viele Kollegen, die das so ein bisschen im Hobby machen oder auch Sportzeitschriften mit herausgeben oder so. Aber man hat das natürlich, auch wenn man andere Schwerpunkte hat, also ich komme jetzt eher so aus dem Kapitalmarktrecht und aus dem Gesellschaftsrecht, immer so im Auge, was dann passiert. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel in Hannover gerade wieder ein Brief ist zwischen den Mehrheitsgesellschaften und dem Verein, dann tütet man das natürlich gedanklich sofort in seine Kategorien ein.
Ja gut, das tut ihr Juristen und Juristinnen ja sowieso, zumindest meinem persönlichen Empfinden nach. Da kann man ja nicht mal eine einfache Bierbestellung aufgeben, ohne dass darüber diskutiert wird, wie binden dieser mündliche Vertrag mit dem Kellner jetzt gerade ist. Aber vielleicht ist das auch nur mein persönlicher Eindruck. Ich freue mich sehr, dass du hier bist und ich freue mich sehr, dass Fabian Reinholz hier ist. Seine Stimme kennt ihr hoffentlich schon aus dem Liebling Bossmann Podcast. Er ist Rechtsanwalt bei den Herting und auch Partner dort bei der Kanzlei Herting. Fabian, schön, dass du hier bist. Bei dir muss man glaube ich nach dem Sportrechtsbezug gar nicht so sehr fragen. Der scheint mir eindeutiger zu sein.
Ja, hallo Max. Ich freue mich auch wahnsinnig hier dabei zu sein, weil ich das Thema auch sehr spannend finde. Ich kann es vielleicht noch ergänzen. Die Kollegen, die im Sportrecht unterwegs sind, machen das meistens aus dem Grunde, weil sie wahnsinnig interessiert am Sport sind. Also ich kenne eigentlich keinen, der dabei ist und sich nicht für Sport interessiert. Und bei mir war das auch so, ich glaube ich 2006, als die WM im eigenen Lande war, fing ich an mich für die Themen zu interessieren, also für die juristischen Fragen dazu. Und dann nahm die Dinge so seinen Lauf.
Die juristischen Fragen der WM 2006, aber du meinst wahrscheinlich nur nicht, wie die WM nach Deutschland kam. Das war dann erst ein bisschen später.
Nee, also zu der damaligen Zeit hat ja jeder gedacht, dass es alles mit rechten Dingen zu ging. Das kam dann erst später. Ich habe mich mehr so um Vermarktungsfragen damals gekümmert, so Public Viewing, darf man Spiele übertragen in Biergärten und wie ist das eigentlich mit dem Markenschutz? Wie ist WM 2006? Kann man das sozusagen monopolisieren veranstalterseitig? Das waren damals sehr, sehr spannende und auch relativ öffentlich diskutierte Fragen.
Oh ja, das berühmte Weltmeisterbrötchen, das eine Bäckerei anbieten wollte und wo dann die Frage war, ist denn das noch erlaubt oder müssten hier die Fiefer nicht schon was bekommen? Die Frage wollen wir jetzt nicht beantworten. Ihr hattet auf jeden Fall schon mal miteinander zu tun, vor vielen, vielen Jahren rund um den Harzplatz-Helden-Prozess. Die Älteren und den Hörern und Hörer werden sich noch erinnern. Heute wollen wir uns allerdings mit einer aktuellen Rechtsprechung auseinandersetzen und zwar mit dem Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes zur Beteiligung der Vereine an Polizeikosten im Rahmen von Hochrisikospielen. Es ist eine relativ lange Einleitung schon mal, um was es hier eigentlich geht. Ich glaube auch deshalb wäre es sinnvoll, wenn wir uns erstmal die Frage stellen, was ist hier eigentlich verhandelt worden, wie ist es auch dazu gekommen. Philipp, du darfst gerne mal loslegen. Wie würdest du denn versuchen, in wenigen Worten zusammenzufassen, worum es hier eigentlich geht?
Also ich würde didaktisch jetzt erstmal jetzt die Geschichte erzählen und dann vielleicht danach ein bisschen auf die juristischen Fallstricke anzugehen, da kann man das nämlich besser sozusagen greifen. Also es ging damit los, dass in 2015 ein Hochrisikospiel war, oder sagen wir jetzt einfach mal ein Spiel zwischen Werder Bremen, also in Bremen und dem HSV, also sozusagen ein freudliches Nachbarschaftstuell. Und da erhielt dann die DFL, also nicht Werder Bremen, sondern die DFL, von der Stadt Bremen, also Bundesland Bremen, ein Gebührenbescheid über 420.000 Euro war das glaube ich. Weil sie gesagt haben, naja, das war ein Hochrisikospiel und wir mussten zusätzliche Polizeikräfte organisieren aus anderen Bundesländern. Die mussten dann anreisen, mussten verpflegt werden und so weiter und so fort. Und das hat, das waren knapp 1000, ich glaube 970 oder so was, Polizeieinsatzkräfte statt der üblichen 150. Und das möchten wir euch jetzt gerne in Rechnung stellen. Und da hat die DFL gesagt, das sehen wir jetzt eigentlich nicht so ein. Aus verschiedenen Gründen sind vor, haben wir es angefochten, diesen Bescheid, sind vor das Verwaltungsgericht Bremen gegangen. Das hat dann gesagt, zwei Jahre später oder anderthalb Jahre später, DFL, ihr habt recht, das geht so nicht. Dann ging die Stadt Bremen vor das Oberverwaltungsgericht. Das hat dann gesagt, naja, doch, das geht schon so. Also VG Bremen hat unrecht. Und es kam, wie es kam, musste. Dann geht es vor das Bundesverwaltungsgericht. Und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat gesagt, ja, OVG hat Recht, VG hat Unrecht, DFL hat Unrecht, Stadt Bremen hat Recht. Also auf gut Deutsch, ja, ihr könnt das abkassieren.
Also steht eins zu zwei für die DFL zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Genau, aber das ist so ein bisschen golden-gold an der Stelle eher.
Ja, stimmt.
Und da gab es jetzt wurde es dann nochmal komplex. Da haben sie aber gesagt, die Berechnung, die finden wir jetzt aber nicht. So ging es wieder zum OVG zurück, wieder zum Bundesverwaltungsgericht zurück. Und das war dann so in 2020, 2021. Und jetzt ging das los, worüber wir eigentlich sprechen. Gegen das letzte Urteil des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts hat dann die DFL eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt in Karlsruhe, also beim Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und diese Entscheidung ist dann jetzt vor einer guten Woche, also am 15. Januar war es, dann publik gemacht worden. Und das ist erstmal so der Hintergrund, was tatsächlich passiert ist.
Und für diejenigen, die sich vielleicht fragen, warum ging denn das erst 2014 los? So Hochrisikospiele gab es ja schon in den 70ern, 80ern, 90ern, da hat man sie vielleicht noch anders betitelt. Dazu muss man noch wissen, dass die Stadt Bremen 2014 eben die Gebührenverordnung für Veranstaltungen, für Großveranstaltungen geändert hat. Und deswegen war es eben dann auch möglich, dann beim nächsten Hochrisikospiel dann eben diese Rechnung zu stellen. Aber das Ganze liegt eben schon zehn Jahre zurück und hat so lange seine Kreise gezogen. Wie ist denn das für euch als Juristen? Da muss ich jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen unsachlich reingehen. Fabian, nimmst du das einfach so zur Kenntnis, dass etwas zehn Jahre dauert, bis es entschieden ist?
Also ich weiß natürlich, dass solche Verfahren so lange dauern. Insofern nehme ich das in der Tat so zur Kenntnis. Ich kann aber durchaus verstehen, dass das Störgefühle auslöst bei Nichtjuristen, die vielleicht nicht so ganz im täglichen Leben damit vertraut sind, wie lange solche Verfahren dauern. Also man darf nicht vergessen, wie viele hier Instanzen mittlerweile beteiligt sind. Allein der Verwaltungsgerichtsweg ist ja schon über drei Instanzen gegangen und das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann eben noch hinten dran. Und naja, da liegen dann diese Verfahren immer schon eine Weile. Tatsächlich muss man aber sagen, das ist jetzt in diesem Fall durchaus eine relativ lange Zeit, die da ins Land gegangen ist. Also das habe ich auch schon schneller erlebt. Aber wenn man sich vielleicht als Vergleich auch der Pechstein-Pfeil, wenn der allen geläufig ist, der ist ja auch durch zahlreiche Instanzen gegangen, vom BGH zum Bundesverfassungsgericht und so weiter. Auch der hat mittlerweile so viel Zeit auf dem Buckel.
Also Claudia Pechstein ist damit natürlich gemeint, ehemalige Eisschnellläuferin. Und ich meine, der namensgebende Fall zu eurem Podcast, das Bosman-Urteil, ich meine klar, das ging bis auf EU-Ebene, das muss dann auch ein bisschen dauern, aber das waren auch glaube ich sieben Jahre und er war schon lange nicht mehr aktiv. Also sprich für ihn hatte es ja dann gar keine direkte Konkurrenten, Konsequenz mehr in seiner Arbeitsweise. Aber das ist ja eigentlich nur ein Nebenthema. Philipp, du hast uns jetzt quasi den Weg beschrieben, man muss dazu sagen, währenddessen sind auch immer wieder neue Rechnungen aufgelaufen. Die DFL hat dann auch begonnen bzw. sie hat es dann weitergereicht an Werder Bremen, Teile dieser Rechnung zu bezahlen, immer unter dem Vorbehalt. Wir legen dagegen Verfassungsbeschwerder ein und das, was man eben machen muss, falls man sein Geld wiederbekommen möchte, sollte es anders ausgegangen sein. Kannst du uns jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr zu den Inhalten sagen, um was geht es eigentlich konkret dann bei diesen Rechnungen? Also was wird da in Rechnung gestellt? Der Mehreinsatz, du hast schon den Begriff Hochrisikospiel verwendet, da werden wir heute noch oft drüber sprechen, glaube ich. Kannst du uns dazu noch mehr sagen?
Genau, also du hast ja auch völlig richtig diese neue Vorschrift aus dem bremischen Gebühren- und Beitragsgesetz, schöner Name, Paragraph 4 Absatz 4. Ich lese mal kurz den Passus vor, um den es geht. Der Begriff Hochrisikospiel kommt da nämlich nicht zuvor und das ist auch wichtig, dann kommen wir bestimmt nachher noch mal drauf. Der sagt, also es können die Gebühren vom Veranstalter erhoben werden, wenn wegen erfahrungsgemäß zu erwartender Gewalthandlungen vor, während oder nach der Veranstaltung am Veranstaltungsort, an den Zugangs- und Abgangswegen oder sonst im räumlichen Umfeld der Einsatz von zusätzlichen Polizeikräften vorhersehbar erforderlich wird. Das ist jetzt die etwas sperrige Definition. Also es geht darum, um zu erwartende Gewalthandlungen. Es geht um vorhersehbare Erforderlichkeit. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, die Idee, dass der Staat sich Geld erstatten lässt für seine Handlung, das ist jetzt nichts grundsturzend Neues. Also ich sag mal, wenn du ganz doof auf einer Feuerwehrzufahrt parkst und du musst abgeschleppt werden, dann kriegst du nicht nur ein Bußgeld, sondern auch eben die Rechnung fürs Abschleppen. So vereinfacht. Dann nennt man Störerhaftung. Und es gab schon lange vorher eine Diskussion drüber, ob sowas eigentlich auch bei Fußballspielen, man kann auch über die Love Parade reden oder sonst was, aber es entzündete sich eben meistens am Fußball, ob das eigentlich auch einschlägig wäre. Und da hat die meisten haben gesagt, in der Literatur und so, die haben gesagt, geht eigentlich nicht, weil der Verein, der stört ja nicht so wirklich. Also ich meine, das sind ja keine Vereinsmitarbeiter, die da aufeinander losgehen, sondern das sind halt Dritte und die machen was Rechtswidriges und das wird schwer. Und vor diesem Hintergrund hat eben Bremen, aber meines Wissensstandes, vielleicht weiß Fabian noch mehr, eben auch nur Bremen diese Satzung erlassen. Und das war eben der Hintergrund, wo das Ganze dann losging. Aber wie gesagt, dieser Mechanismus, der Bürger tut etwas und dafür wird er zur Kasse gebeten. Das ist jetzt nichts grundstürzend Neues, was jetzt, daraus haben sich aber zwei Fragen ergeben. Ich muss das jetzt ein bisschen vermischen, weil es gibt insgesamt fünf normale Entscheidungen und eine Verfassungsbeschwerde dazu. Das heißt, in jeder Instanz ist mal was anderes so betont worden. Aber wenn man es mal so in der Draufsicht sagt, ein Argument war, das geht nicht, weil das ist ein Polizeieinsatz und der wird auch Steuergeldern bezahlt. Dafür ist der Stab da, da kann man sich das jetzt nicht zurückholen. Das war das Erste. Das Zweite, was total umstritten war, naja, die DFL ist überhaupt die DFL-Veranstalter. Das war ja auch in der Intro kurz zu hören. Oder ist es der Fußballverein, der Fußballklub? Das war dann das Zweite. Und, worum ging es noch? Ja klar, die sogenannte Unterbrechung der Kausalkette. Also was kann Bremen oder die DFL dafür, wenn da plötzlich sich Huls zur dritten Halbzeit verabreden? Das waren so wahrscheinlich die drei großen Problemfelder. Da gab es noch andere, aber ich glaube auf die drei können wir uns wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen konzentrieren in der Diskussion.
Und jetzt ist es ja so, du hast es Golden Goal genannt. Also wenn mal was bis zum Bundesverfassungsgericht gegangen ist, selbst wenn die DFL 4 zu 0 geführt hätte bis dorthin, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, nein, wir sehen das so und so, dann dreht das alles um. Also ist es dann für uns ein pragmatischer Weg, wenn wir uns auf das Bundesverfassungsgericht urteilen und die Begründung beschränken und das Vorhierige kann man zwar im Wissen mitnehmen, aber im Grunde, das ist ja jetzt das, an dem man sich orientieren muss. Ist das korrekt so?
Genau. Und jetzt kommt aber ein Juratrick. Ich sag grundsätzlich schon. Grundsätzlich bedeutet das. Es kommt halt so ein bisschen drauf an. Wir sollten uns auf das Verfahren, also auf das Bundesverfassungsgericht beschränken. Aber die Vorinstanzen haben teilweise auch durchaus ein, zwei interessante Sachen mal so gesagt, die man zumindest als Argumente, ohne jetzt sich darauf zu stürzen, später vielleicht nochmal einfließen lassen kann. Was ich ganz, ganz wichtig finde jetzt, auch weil es ja kein Genuiner-Jura-Podcast hier ist. Ich möchte kurz mal sagen, was der Stefan Habert, das ist der Vorsitzende des Senats und damit auch der Vorsitzende des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, also der ist wichtig, in der Pressekonferenz gesagt hat. Er hat gesagt, ausdrücklich der Senat, also wir haben nicht darüber entschieden, ob die Bremer Gebühren-Regelung politisch klug oder wünschenswert ist. Also alles worüber wir jetzt erstmal reden ist die juristische Analyse und weniger drum, ob das jetzt gut, böse oder sonst was ist. Das war dem Verfassungsgerichtspräsidenten so wichtig, weil er wusste, dass das jetzt so rezipiert wird in den Medien, dass er das nochmal ausdrücklich darstellen wollte.
Wobei ja die politische Ebene dieses ganzen Aspekts noch mal so komplex und weiterführend ist. Das fängt ja schon damit an, dass sich nur ein Bundesland und Ulrich Meurer, jemand der nicht als Fußballfan bekannt ist, getraut hat in Anführungszeichen das alles anzustoßen. Und er hat das immer wieder beschrieben. Also es gibt viele viele Berichterstattungen rund eben um die vorherigen Verfahren. Ich könnte zum Beispiel den Sport Inside Podcast aus dem Jahr 2022, den kann ich dazu sehr empfehlen mit Matthias Wolf. Der erzählt nämlich auch noch mal, welchen Anfeindungen Ulrich Meurer nicht nur von Fußballfans ausgesetzt war, sondern auch von Innenministerkollegen und anderen Menschen aus der Politik, die beinharte Fußballfans sind, anders als er und die gesagt haben, was machst du denn hier? Du entziehst uns die Wettbewerbsgrundlage. Also auch das erklärt glaube ich so einiges der Aufregung rund um dieses Urteil und vielleicht auch warum manches so ein bisschen schief rezipiert wurde. Da haben wir glaube ich schon Beispiele im Intro gehört. Vielleicht habe ich später auch nochmal die Gelegenheit, da was einzuspielen. Wenn wir dann jetzt mal versuchen aufzudröseln, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat, wie war denn die Argumentationslinie, wie dieses Urteil begründet wurde?
Das war eine Verfassungsbeschwerde. Zum Bundesverfassungsgericht kann grundsätzlich jeder gehen, aber nicht einfach so. Also man muss betroffen sein und man muss vorher auch schon diese ganze siebenjährige Entscheidungspyramide durchlaufen haben. Und deshalb ging es eben wie gesagt auch um die DFL und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat halt verschiedene, ich mache es jetzt mal relativ kurz und relativ schnell, was er so gesagt hat. Zunächst hat er gesagt, ja gut, das ist schon richtig, dass es eine steuerfinanzierte Leistung ist, die Polizei. Aber wir sehen jetzt keinen Grundsatz, warum nicht zusätzlich Gebühren erhoben werden sollten. Und haben mal kurz vor der eigenen Haustür geguckt, haben gesagt, hey, wenn ich zum Bericht gehe, muss ich auch Gebühren bezahlen. Das ist schon ein sehr eingängiges Argument. Dann haben sie gesagt, zweitens, also es ist schon angemessen, und das ist eine wichtige Argumentation und ein richtiger Spin der ganzen Sache, es ist schon angemessen, den wirtschaftlichen Nutznießer einer Großveranstaltung an sozusagen den finanziellen Aspekten zu beteiligen. Sie haben also nicht gesagt, derjenige, der was falsch gemacht hat, der sich da prügeln will, der recht zwiedrig handelt, sondern sie haben eben auf diese kommerzielle Schiene abgestellt. Sie haben also gesagt, der sozusagen polizeiliche Störer, der Baddie, das ist nicht notwendigerweise das Gleiche wie der, von dem wir jetzt die Gebühren fordern und das ist grundsätzlich auch okay. Und dann haben sie als dritten Punkt noch gesagt, naja, das ist jetzt wunderschöner Begriff, von dem wir es vorhin schon hatten. Das ist auch angemessen. Also das Ziel ist legitim und es ist auch nicht unverhältnismäßig, denn es kommt an dieser Stelle zu keiner Erdrosselung. Das steht dann tatsächlich dann so drin, also es wird nicht erdrosselt finanziell, weil die DFL ja halt ziemlich umsatzstarkes Gebilde ist. Und da kann man sich an der Stelle schon mal fragen, wie wäre es denn eigentlich, wenn wir bei sowas vom Dritt- oder Viertligisten reden würden. Also da merkt man schon, dass diese Entscheidung halt sehr auf die DFL und dieses konkrete Verfahren natürlich gemünzt ist.
Fabian?
Vielleicht kann ich dazu kurz was sagen. Hinzu kommt ja noch, dass die DFL, jetzt aus meiner Erinnerung und ich kann mich entsinnen, dass ich schon auf sportrechtlichen Veranstaltungen war, bevor es diesen Passus in der Gebührenordnung in Bremen gab. Die Bremer aber tatsächlich, da glaube ich, auch saßen bei solchen Veranstaltungen. Also bevor die DFL ins Spiel kam, war ja die Diskussion, ob man eigentlich die Vereine in Anspruch nimmt, die ja nun klassischerweise Veranstalter sind. Die DFL ist, das hatte Philipp ja vorhin richtig gesagt, das ist überhaupt die Frage, ob die eigentlich Mitveranstalter oder auch Veranstalter sind und dort in Anspruch genommen werden können. Auch bei den Vereinen stellt sich ja schon die Frage, ob das nicht eine erhebliche Belastung darstellt, da mal eben für zwei oder drei Spiele pro Saison 400.000 Euro erstatten zu müssen. Nur man hat das charmant umgangen, indem man sich die DFL hergenommen hat, bei der man offensichtlich davon ausgeht, dass die Kassen gefüllt sind bei Milliardeneinnahmen durch die TV-Vermarktung und hat damit auch so ein bisschen diese politisch etwas komplexe Situation umgangen, wo die Vereine dann auch gesagt hätten, Leute, wir prägen sozusagen das soziale Leben in dem jeweiligen Bundesland doch sehr stark. Und dafür bittet ihr uns jetzt auch noch zur Kasse. Das ist sozusagen diese politische Dimension, die da drinsteckt und die hat man, ja, die hat man eben aus der Gefecht gesetzt, indem man sich gleich an die DFL gewandt hat. Und die DFL ist, muss man natürlich auch sagen, als Mitveranstalter, als der sie sich selbst sieht, dann natürlich ein willkommener Adressat.
Aber ich meine, das geht jetzt schon ein bisschen in den Bereich der Diskussion rein, aber wenn wir schon an diesem Punkt sind, also dass es eine solche erdrossende Wirkung, also sprich, dass jemand nicht mehr wirtschaftlich handeln kann, seine Veranstaltung nicht mehr wirtschaftlich ist, wenn er eben diese Mehrkosten zu tragen hat. Was eben ganz wichtig ist, wenn man jetzt versucht, dieses Beispiel auf andere Großveranstaltungen anzuwenden, dass das mitberücksichtigt wird, das liegt ja nahe. Und dass man das bei kleineren Vereinen auch wirklich wahrscheinlich auch verargumentieren kann, dass wenn wir eben jetzt zum Beispiel dann über Regionallegisten oder Drittlegisten sprechen, wir haben Joachim Herrmann, den bayerischen Innenminister im Intro gehört, der genau gleich das gesagt hat, das war der wunderbare Oton, in dem die ostdeutschen Fans da natürlich genannt wurden. Das ist dann vielleicht auch eine bayerische Eigenart, da so gut mit dem Finger auf jemanden zu zeigen. Aber genau darum geht es ja, dass es da eben eine solche Argumentationslinie geben könnte, dass man sagen kann, also das kann jetzt dann unter Haching nicht leisten, da jetzt dann mehrere hunderttausend an Polizeikosten zu zahlen. Aber auf der anderen Seite widerspricht das doch total dem Gefühl, dass alle Menschen haben und ja auch der Tatsache, dass extrem viel Geld im Fußball ist. Also wenn in der Lage der Nation, die wir auch gehört haben, anderer Podcast im Intro schon, wenn da relativ oberflächlich ehrlicherweise über dieses Urteil diskutiert wird, also die Fakten waren alle richtig, aber die Diskussion dazu war sehr, sehr fußballfern. Aber wenn da gesagt wird, naja insgesamt kämen da im Jahr wahrscheinlich 15 bis 20 Millionen Euro auf die DFL zu, das ist einmal das Jahresgehalt von Manuel Neuer, dann ist das doch nicht falsch, oder?
Uff, definitiv. Also ich muss sagen, mit mir streiten da so zwei Herzen. Also wäre ich jetzt kein Fußballfan, würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, ja das ist alles in sich schlüssig, das ist, das versteht man, das kann ja nicht sein, wenn man Manuel Neuer ist ein gutes Beispiel, man kann den Gesamtumsatz nehmen und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man sich das dann irgendwie auch von den Vereinen wieder zurückholt, was wiederum anderes Thema ist, das müssen wir glaube ich nachher auch noch mal kurz anschneiden, wie man das eigentlich machen sollte, klingt das für mich alles sehr, sehr logisch. Aber als Fußballfan, ich hab dann halt trotzdem ein massives Störgefühl und wenn man sich das nachher juristisch weiterdenkt, ich mein, mein ganz, ganz kleines Beispiel, wenn wir sagen, der, ich mein, ich kann nur vor Gericht gehen, wenn ich sozusagen selbst betroffen bin. Wenn jetzt die DFL eine Rechnung an Bremen schickt, dann kann Bremen sich da nicht gegen wehren. Ja, die können, also Florian, Entschuldigung, Fabian, du bist der Praktiker, aber wie würde das denn dann weiterlaufen? Also da hab ich in verschiedenen Grundsätzen auch echte Störgefühle. Aber wir müssen sehen, sagen, es stimmt, die DFL hat einfach sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und andersrum ist es auch nicht so ganz einzusehen, dass der Staat das dann halt bezahlt, wenn es schon Grundsätze gibt, die eine sozusagen eine Rückerstattung ermöglichen. Also ich verstehe die Kritiker da auf einer rationalen Ebene.
Also da es gibt in der Bremer Gebührenordnung übrigens eine Billigkeitsschranke, ich glaube 25 oder so ist das. Da gibt es schon die Möglichkeit im Rahmen der Festsetzung der Gebühren auf Besonderheiten Rücksicht zu nehmen. Also zum Beispiel, dass der Adressat eben nicht so viel auf der hohen Kante hat, wie jemand anderes, so verstehe ich das. Muss aber sagen, dass ich mich jetzt nicht allzu tief damit beschäftigt habe. Aber es gibt natürlich ein paar Gesichtspunkte, die muss man einfach mal ansprechen. Also, ja, Lage in den Nationen habe ich gehört. Teile übrigens nicht die allgemeine Meinung, dass das da wahnsinnig oberflächlich behandelt wurde. Es ist allerdings so, dass dieses Zitat, was du vorhin eingespielt hast, Max, das ist natürlich so ein bisschen so ein bisschen verklärte Vorstellungen davon, wie der Fußball eigentlich ist. Insofern ist da die Kritik angebracht.
Also das Hooligans, ganze Städte in Schutt und Asche legen, das ist jetzt ein Zitat.
Ja, genau. Also dass das in so einem Kriegsszenario irgendwie man sich vorstellt oder dass das, sagen wir mal, auch gang und gäbe ist im Fußball. So ist es ja nicht. Ja, und damit fängt es im Prinzip an, dass den Fans einmal pauschal vorgeworfen wird, sie seien eigentlich von Hause aus Krawallmacher. Und dem Vereinen oder der Fußballorganisation wird offensichtlich auch unterstellt, sie legen die Hände in den Schoß und lassen das einfach mal so machen. Das stimmt ja schon mal nicht. Also zum einen wissen wir alle, dass die Fan-Gruppierung, dass die sogenannten Ultras keine Karoten oder Krawallmacher sind, sondern dass es immer einzelne Grüppchen sind, die in der Tat allerdings auch es darauf anlegen, Gewalt auszuüben mit gegnerischen Fan-Gruppen, die auch körperlich gut vorbereitet sind auf sowas. Aber das sind eben einzelne Gruppen und das sind nicht der Fußballfan an sich. Und die Vereine tun wahnsinnig viel, also die viele jedenfalls tun wahnsinnig viel dafür, um diese Fan-Gewalt irgendwo eindämmen oder beschränken zu können. Da gibt es Fanbeauftragte, da gibt es wahnsinnig viel Kommunikation mit den Fan-Gruppen, mit den Ultras. Man nimmt auch die Fans sozusagen mit, damit die selbst dafür sorgen, innerhalb ihrer Fan-Gruppierungen ein Auge darauf zu haben, wer ist da gefährlich und das irgendwie so ein bisschen steuern zu können. Also da tut sich schon seit Jahren viel. Und insofern findet das so ein bisschen wenig Berücksichtigung in der Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts. Kätzerisch könnte man ja auch sagen, die Fangewalt ist ja im Prinzip nicht durch den Fußball erfunden worden, sondern sie ist eine Begleiterscheinung, aber sie hat natürlich auch Gründe, die, glaube ich, in der Gesellschaft zu suchen sind. Und dafür ist aber nicht der Fußball verantwortlich, sondern dafür ist auch die Allgemeinheit mitverantwortlich und insofern auch der Staat. Insofern finde ich das so ein bisschen schwierig, jetzt an diesem konkreten Beispiel Fußball, da ausschließlich die Vereine und die DFL in die Haftung zu nehmen.
Aber wen würde man sonst in die Haftung nehmen wollen? Also ja, man kann da eine gesellschaftliche Tendenz sehen. Und es wäre natürlich ganz wunderbar, wenn wir an diesem Beispiel jetzt mal über etwas Größeres sprechen könnten, nämlich über toxische Männlichkeit, über Alkoholkonsum, über den Zusammenhang zwischen Alkohol und Gewalt, über die Verbreitung von Gewaltvideos über soziale Messenger wie Telegram und andere. Da gibt es ja riesige Gruppen. Also all das könnte man ja sehr gerne mal anhand dieses Beispiels diskutieren. Und das würde ich mich, würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen. Es hört halt nur leider meinem Empfinden nach sehr früh beim Fußball auf, weil es sehr einfach ist, beim Fußball drauf zu hauen, weil es viele negative Auswirkungen gibt. Die sollte man nicht wegreden. Also wer schon mal mit Fußballfans in einem Zug saß, der weiß, das ist nicht angenehm, dann ist deine Zugfahrt dahin. Egal ob die gewonnen oder verloren haben. Wer schon mal das Pech hatte, irgendwie am Bahnhof zu stehen, wenn da eine Ferngruppierung angekommen ist, der wird das auch nicht als unbedrohlich empfunden haben. Also das sind natürlich Eindrücke, die in der Allgemeinheit verhaftet sind, weil sie ja auch stimmen. Das Problem ist nur, dass wir hier eine ständige Vermischung haben von Begriffen wie Hooligans und Ultras und eine Pauschalisierung, die absolut nicht zutreffend ist, die dann auch zu völlig falschen Schlussfolgerungen führt. Also da spiele ich jetzt mal ein Beispiel aus der Lage der Nation ein. Das hat Ulf Burmeier dann gesagt.
Wenn jetzt also de facto diese Chaoten für die Vereine richtig teuer werden, weil die Chaoten nämlich dazu führen, dass Kostenbescheide verschickt werden können, dann engagieren sich die Vereine vielleicht in Zukunft wirksam dafür, dass die Fans friedlich bleiben. Ich meine, es gibt ja schon ohne Ende Fanarbeit. Die hat ja wirklich keine Experte, die hat ja wohl auch positive Wirkung. Würde ich so ausbetrachtet auch sagen, ja. Trotzdem gibt es immer noch Hooligans ohne Ende und vielleicht führt ja diese Kostenbeteiligung der Vereine auch dazu, dass die Hooligans einfach merken, wenn wir das machen, dann schaden wir unserem eigenen Verein. Vielleicht ist das eine blöde Idee.
Und wir alle drei in der Runde haben jetzt gelächelt für alle diejenigen, die den Podcast nur gehört haben, weil jeder der sich ein bisschen mit Hooliganismus auskennt und mit gewaltbereiten Fans, der weiß, die werden sich nicht davon abhalten lassen, dass ihr Verein dafür zahlen muss. Also das ist einfach völlig weltfremd und das ist jetzt auch nicht schlimm, dass Ulf Buermeyer das nicht weiß, aber auf dieser Ebene der Diskussion kommt man halt dann nicht weiter. Und dann vor allem bleibt man halt beim Fußball und redet vielleicht nicht über die größeren Zusammenhänge, obwohl es richtig ist, den Fußball in die Verantwortung zu nehmen, würde ich schon sagen. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein Grundsatzproblem, was wir bei der Diskussion rund um dieses Urteil haben. Ich denke mal, Philipp, du hast da auch Anmerkungen zu.
Ja, ich meine, das muss noch klar sagen. Wir reden hier nicht davon, ob jetzt Pyro abgebrannt werden sollte im Stadion und so was oder den Einfluss der Ultras im Stadion. Das ist überhaupt nicht das Thema dieser Entscheidung. Also wir reden genau wie du gesagt hast, im Zweifelsfall, der Begriff Chaot ist schlecht, aber wir wissen es im Zweifelsfall alle, das sind halt Gewaltbereite, die würden sich im Zweifelsfall oder viele von ihnen wahrscheinlich irgendwo anders ein Ventil suchen und die Stimme von kannst du, das passiert nicht. Ich wollte übrigens noch kurz sagen, was Fabian gesagt hat, ganz wichtig mit diesem Passus in der Abgabenordnung, mit dieser Billigkeitsklausel. Genau das wurde in den Entscheidungen übrigens auch mal gesagt. Also das Bundesverwaltungsgericht war es glaube ich, naja in der dritten, vierten Liga müsste man das Ganze wohl auch einschränkend auslegen. Also auf gut Deutsch, da kommt man damit nicht so einfach durch. Deshalb glaube ich, um vielleicht noch mal die Brücke zu vorherzuschlagen, dass was in dieser Entscheidung so heiß gekocht wird oder heiß geredet wird, nach allem gar nicht mal so heiß ist, wenn man es isst. Wir müssen uns vielleicht auch mal fragen, ist das Ganze vielleicht auch ein Bremer-Problem? Du hast das Politische, weil wir reden ja eigentlich schon wieder über das Politische und weniger über das Rechtliche oder wie weit man es überhaupt trennen kann. Bremen ist ein sehr kleines Bundesland, das verdammt wenig Geld hat. Da ist natürlich auch die Verlockung so etwas dann zu tun. Viel höher als es zum Beispiel auch bei uns hier in München zum Beispiel wäre. Das ist vielleicht auch ein ganz anderes Effekt. Da muss ich auch überlegen, wie die anderen Bundesländer das sehen. Aber mein Gedankengang, als du den O-Ton gespielt hast, da hat sie gesagt, das hab ich schon so oft gehört. Und nein Leute, ist das einfach nicht so.
Ja und auf der anderen Seite stimmt es aber auch, dass also beides ist richtig. Die DFL-Vereine, die in der DFL organisierten Vereine zahlen, auch übersteuern schon für so etwas wie Polizeieinsätze. Es ist nicht so, dass sie nichts zahlen würden und das sind nicht so wenige. Sie fassen das immer zu einer möglichst hohen Summe zusammen, weil auch alle Sozialabgaben mit dabei sind, aber sie 1,6 Milliarden Euro waren es in der Saison 2022, 2023 von der DFL so kommuniziert. Das ist natürlich eine hohe Summe. Also das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass sie nichts tun würden. Auf der anderen Seite stimmt es aber natürlich auch, dass der Aufwand enorm ist rund um solche Hochrisikospiele. Also die Polizeistunden, die zum Beispiel eingesetzt wurden, also die Arbeitsbelastung für Polizeibeamtinnen und Beamte 2023, 2024 ist um 1,2 Prozent gestiegen, obwohl es 4,4 Prozent weniger Spiele gab in diesem Zeitraum. Das waren 2,4 Millionen Stunden. Man spricht immer davon, dass rund 1.300 Vollzeitstellen geschaffen werden könnten, wenn man eben das Geld einnehmen würde, was die Polizei gerne in Rechnung stellen würde. Das ist eben auch wahr, dass es eben ein enorm hoher Einsatz ist an Männern und Frauen, die eben an jedem Bundesligaspieltag nicht nur im Umfeld von Stadien, sondern ja auch an Bahnhöfen und so weiter ihren Dienst schieben. Gleichzeitig stimmt aber auch und vielleicht ist das dann ein weiterer Diskussionspunkt, den wir dann aufmachen könnten, dass die Polizei selbst über ihren Aufwand entscheidet. Also ein Hochrisikospiel wird auf zweierlei Art definiert. Zum einen Heimmannschaft und Gastteam, die bewerten in meinem Ampelsystem grün, gelb, rot, wie sie die Gefahren und Sicherheitslage einschätzen. Also es geht nicht nur um Gewalt, es geht auch um andere Großveranstaltungen, es geht um wie war das Spiel in der Hinrunde und so weiter und so fort. Also da geht es nicht nur um, aber die Gesamtsicherheitslage. Und die Polizei gibt noch mal eine eigene Einschätzung ab. Und das ist aber dann so ein bisschen wie der Golden Goal. Also was die Polizei sagt, das zählt dann auf jeden Fall. Und Fabian, da haben wir ja dann quasi eigentlich einen der wesentlichen Knackpunkte, dass die bisherige Art und Weise, mit der ein normales Fußballspiel zu einem Hochrisikospiel wird und damit zu etwas, was eben ab jetzt beim bei entsprechenden Gebührenverordnungen abgerechnet werden könnte, dass diese Entscheidung intransparent erfolgt. Und zumindest all denjenigen, die den Fußball enger verfolgen, fallen auch viele Beispiele ein, wo es einfach nach außen hin gar nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist, warum jetzt zum Beispiel Wolfsburg gegen Bremen auf einmal ein Hoch-Risikospiel sein muss und die Bremer-Fans eingekesselt werden am Hauptbahnhof. Da gibt es von außen keinerlei Begründung für.
Ja, völlig richtig. Also die Einschätzung der Gefahrenlage, die objekt ja komplett in Behörden. Da mag es dann natürlich aus der Vergangenheit Erfahrungs-Sätze geben. Aber trotzdem kann man sozusagen die Schablone dann nicht immer gleich anlegen. Und insofern fürchten dann die betroffenen Vereine zurecht, dass die Polizei im Zweifel davon ausgeht, hier mit einem übermäßigen Polizeiaufgebot zusätzlich dann vielleicht auch noch unterstützt durch Wasserwerfer oder andere Dinge, da ein Abwehrszenario aufzubauen, was der eigentlichen Gefahrenlage gar nicht gerecht wird. Da könnte man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch mehrere dieser Folgen machen, auch noch Fan-Vertreter oder Fan-Anwälte einladen, die regelmäßig Fans in Auseinandersetzungen mit den staatlichen Hoheitsträgern, mit den Ermittlungsbehörden vertreten und sagen, da wird also ganz häufig viel zu hart draufgehauen bzw. so Fans unter Generalverdacht gestellt, sie seien eben Krawallmacher. Und insofern finde ich diese Stimmung nachvollziehbar, dass man da jetzt einfach sich wehrlos fühlt gegenüber der Einschätzung der Behörden, was jetzt ein Hochrisikospiel ist zum einen und was die angemessenen Maßnahmen dafür sind, die präventiv gegen mögliche Gewalt vorzugehen. Und das kann man dann, also man kann es natürlich gewissermaßen steuern, also es in der gesetzlichen Norm steht ja drin, das ist sozusagen eine Vorinformation, der Vereine gibt seitens der Ermittlungsbehörden bzw. seitens der Polizei, mit was sie jetzt hier zu rechnen haben. Da kann man natürlich auch im Verwaltungsrechtsweg dann im Nachgang auch gegen die Höhe der Gebühren sich auch was machen. Nur es ist dann jedenfalls stand jetzt einfach völlig fraglich, wer dann, also nach welchen Grundsätzen, nach welchen Maßstäben und der Heranziehung welcher Beweise oder welcher Tatsachen man da zu einem Ergebnis kommen möchte. Also ist es sozusagen völlig offen, was dann in solchen Streitigkeiten um die Höhe der Gebühren rauskommt. Und das ist natürlich unschön. Also weil man hat dann sozusagen auf Seiten der Betroffenen ist man dann relativ frustriert, weil man sagt, naja gut, also die Polizei fährt da jetzt wahnsinnig auf. Natürlich in dem Wissen, sie können ja die Gebühren danach umlegen und dann macht man im Zweifel vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr, als man tatsächlich muss.
Und den Eindruck hat man ja jetzt schon. Also das ist etwas, das ist mit Menschen, die nicht so nah am Fußball dran sind, mit denen ich diskutiert habe in den letzten Tagen, die haben ein anderes Empfinden. Jeder hat seine eigene Perspektive. Die Perspektive von Nicht-Fußballfans ist, dass man wahnsinnig genervt ist von diesen Horden an besoffenen Männern, die in Vorgärten pinken und die sich manchmal auch gegenseitig auf die Mütze hauen. Vielleicht aber nicht ganz so oft, wie man es eigentlich selbst einschätzt und mit denen man nicht Bahn fahren möchte, um es mal so zu sagen. Das ist die eine Perspektive. Die andere Perspektive ist diejenige der Polizei, die an jedem Wochenende Tausende von Bereitschaftspolizistinnen und Polizistinnen und andere Kräfte zusammenziehen muss, um dem irgendwie Herr zu werden. Und die offensichtlich auch das Gefühl hat, das nur mit drakonischen Maßnahmen zum Teil erreichen zu können. Alle versuche es mal mit weniger Polizeipräsenz zu versuchen. Da gab es auch mal ein Pilotprojekt in NRW, das ist einfach im Sande verlaufen. Und jetzt unter dem Begriff der Stadion-Allianz versucht man das ein bisschen zu kaschieren. Aber de facto ist die Polizeipräsenz nicht zurückgegangen. Und die dritte Perspektive ist dann diejenige der, derjenigen, die tatsächlich auch in Stadion gehen, die eigentlich am besten wissen, wie es auch in Stadion ist. Es ist nämlich nicht unsicher in Stadion. Ich hätte die Zahlen dabei. Ich könnte sie nochmal genau nennen. Die aber eben auch erleben, dass sie in einen Generalverdacht gestellt werden, unter einen Generalverdacht stellen, dass sie an Hundertschaften von Polizistinnen und Polizisten manchmal vorbei rennen, dass sie manchmal eingekesselt werden, dass es Identifikations-Feststellungsmaßnahmen gibt, wo Hunderte dafür bestraft werden, dass einige wenige vielleicht etwas getan haben. Und eben ganz konkret, dass es Wasserwerfer im Umfeld von Stadien gibt, was völlig absurd ist eigentlich, wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie die überhaupt zum Einsatz kommen sollten. Also welche Art der Gefahrenlage muss es geben, dass es wirklich Sinn ergäbe, mit einem Wasserwerfer da rein zu peitschen in die Menge? Da fallen mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so viele Szenarien ein und das ist auch ein Fakt. Ich bin zum Beispiel nach dem Spiel Stuttgart gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, war ich auf der Autobahn rund um Stuttgart und habe vier Wasserwerfer überholt, auf der mittleren Spur natürlich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und dachte mir noch, okay, was für eine Demo war denn hier? Und dann ist mir eingefallen, das war irgendwann nachts um 23 Uhr. Ach Moment, heute hat ja Stuttgart gegen Eintracht Frankfurt gespielt und klar, da waren vier Wasserwerfer zugegen oder vielleicht waren es auch nur drei, aber drei in jedem Fall. Und warum waren die da? Ach so, ja, weil beim Hinspiel, da gab es Probleme und da haben wir allerdings auch erlebt, dass die Polizei behauptet hat, da hätten sich Fans miteinander geprügelt. Stuttgarter und Eintracht Frankfurt-Fans, it turns out, nee, Stuttgarter waren da nie beteiligt und es ist eher eine Eskalation zwischen Polizei und Fans gewesen und viele, viele unbeteiligte Fans haben hier in dem Fall auch selbst dokumentiert, dass sie Polizeigewalt erlebt hätten, ohne jetzt da ins Detail enttauchen zu wollen. Aber das zeigt ja schon, wie unterschiedlich die Perspektiven sind und wie leicht es dann auch ist, innerhalb einer Perspektive zu verharren und die andere einfach nicht mehr anzuerkennen. Und da hat jetzt Philipp das Bundesverfassungsgericht so ein Vlog reingehauen, hat gesagt grundsätzlich ist das möglich und hat nicht eigentlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht damit gesagt, ihr müsstet jetzt eigentlich mal diese Diskussion führen, aber sie können es eben nicht so deutlich formulieren, weil sie sollen ja juristisch sprechen und nicht politisch.
Das ist genau das, warum ich das vorhin von dem Stefan Harbert vorgelesen hab. Das hat er damit ja getan, indem er gesagt hat Leute, wir entscheiden hier rein juristisch, nur auf Grundlage der DFL, nur auf Grundlage dieser Gebührenordnung. Und was hier politisch klug ist, er hat ja gesagt politisch klug und wünschenswert. Ich halte das für ziemlich bemerkenswert. Also wie weit er sich damit, also das ist eigentlich so weit, wie man bei dem als Verfassungsrichter eigentlich gehen kann, um zu sagen so Leute, ist es eigentlich nicht so ganz unser Thema. Und das liest man auch aus den anderen Urteilen so ein bisschen an verschiedenen Stellen raus. Also noch die Motte, wir müssen das jetzt. Die Richter wissen ja alle, jeder Richter, der damit befasst ist, weiß, hier geht es nicht um eine kleine Steuerangelegenheit, sondern jeder weiß, hier gucken alle Leute drauf. Und deshalb gibt man sich besonders viel Mühe. Aber deshalb ist man sich ja schon besonders bewusst, was man da sagt und was man da reinschreibt. Aber ist richtig, eigentlich ist es ein politisches Thema. Und das Verfassungsrecht hat eben, genau wie du sagst, nur gesagt, grundsätzlich kann es so gehen. Aber mir sagen wir dazu jetzt auch nicht. Und was die Politik jetzt daraus macht, das ist jetzt eigentlich die spannende Frage.
Also sitzen viele Fußballfans in den Innenministerien und in anderen Ministerien. Andererseits wäre die Grundstimmung glaube ich in der Bevölkerung so, dass du dir sehr leicht jetzt Geld vom Fußball holen könntest. Und das wäre jetzt auch nicht der schlimme Wettbewerbsvorteil, als der das immer dargestellt wird. Also auch das kann ich hier nochmal kurz erzählen. Es ist nämlich tatsächlich so, dass Deutschland die einzige Top-Liga ist, die nicht bisher an Polizeikosten in irgendeiner Art und Weise beteiligt wird. Es gibt in allen anderen Ländern gibt es dazu Regelungen. Also in England und Spanien müssen zum Beispiel die Kosten, die im Stadion und rund um den Stadionumlauf verursacht werden, die müssen von den Vereinen getragen werden. In Frankreich muss man pauschal pro Einsatzstunde 20 Euro zahlen. Es ist ein Wunder, dass es die Liga noch gibt, wenn man da mal länger drüber nachdenkt.
Also pro Person? Pro Polizist?
Pro Einsatzstunde. Boah, danke.
Kann man rechnen bei tausend Polizisten.
Und in Italien gibt es eine prozentuale Abgabe von den Ticket-Einnahmen, die eben generell für Polizeikosten aufgebracht wird. Das heißt, das Argument, die Bundesliga sei nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig, wettbewerbsfähig, wenn sie jetzt beteiligt werden würde, das darf man so nicht gelten lassen. Also das kann man da sehr, sehr schnell vom Tisch wischen. Dann wirtschaften sie einfach noch schlechter, als es eh schon von außen aussieht, wenn sie quasi nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind, wenn sie etwas Ähnliches machen müssen, was in anderen Ländern schon längst der Fall ist. Aber das bringt uns, finde ich, noch mal zu einem Punkt, da würde mich deine Meinung interessieren, Fabian, und sehr gerne dann auch deine, Philipp. Und zwar, das Bundesverfassungsgericht musste ja die Frage klären, der Kausalität zwischen eben der Veranstaltung, der Gewalt, der Gewaltneigung und eben dann der Frage, ist es dann eben auch verhältnismäßig dafür, eine Gebühr zu verlangen? Und da wurde ja unter anderem auch damit argumentiert, die Vereine profitieren davon, dass diese Hochrisikospiele dennoch in einem sicheren Umfeld stattfinden. Ganz interessant, das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, dass auch Hochrisikospiele sicher sind. Merkt euch das, wenn das nächste Mal Rainer Wendt den Mund aufmacht, aber das nur hier nebenher. Aber auch da, und so kann man natürlich argumentieren. Die Frage wäre natürlich, wie wäre es, wenn wir nicht 1000 Polizistinnen und Polizisten da hätten, muss es dieser Aufwand sein? Das ist jetzt eine praktische Frage. Wir haben ja aber auch noch eine örtliche Frage. Also ist es die Aufgabe der Vereine, kann es die Aufgabe der Vereine sein, dass sie für eine Handlung irgendwo im Stadtumfeld verantwortlich gemacht werden? Vielleicht ja auch von Fans, die jetzt gar nicht wirklich Fans des Vereins sind. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass sich da Leute untermischen, aber was man ja zum Beispiel manchmal hat, dass es ein Hochrisikospiel gibt zwischen Schalke und einem anderen Verein und dann gibt es irgendeine Fan-Freundschaft mit Dortmund und dann auf einmal kommen da Dortmunder Fans und kloppen sich irgendwo, ehrlich gesagt eher auf dem Acker, wo man es nicht mitbekommt und wo auch nur denjenigen was passiert und wo die Polizei auch strategisch in die andere Richtung guckt. Was hätte dann Schalke 04 in dem Sinne damit zu tun? Also findest du diese Argumentation des Bundesverfassungsgerichts schlüssig?
Nein, muss ich sagen. Also wir kommen ja zu dem Punkt, den ich vor allem so ein bisschen schwierig finde, dass man, dass der Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, die Bundesliga ist im Prinzip der Nutznießer dieser ganzen polizeilichen Vorbeigungsmaßnahmen, weil man im Grunde die Spiele und das Umfeld sicher macht und die Bundesliga daran wirtschaftlich profitiert. Ja, indem sie sich beispielsweise erspart eigene Sicherheitsdienste, wobei man hier natürlich wieder einschränkend sagen muss, die eigenen Sicherheitsdienste kann sie natürlich nicht in der Stadt einsetzen, weil da hat das Gewaltmonopol tatsächlich der Staat. Also da hat auch ein Verein mit seinen Sicherheitskräften überhaupt nichts zu suchen und der Staat macht das im Zweifel besser und das ist auch der Grund, weshalb er da das Monopol hat. Also das ist eine ziemliche Gemengelage, da sozusagen die Sicherheit der Stadt und die Sicherheit des Umfelds und des Bahnhofs quasi in die Verantwortung der Vereine zu legen. Das können die Vereine nicht und das können sie auch, ob er lichter betrachtet, nicht beherrschen. Der Staat könnte das im Übrigen schonen. Also man hat ja eigentlich auch noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen, inwieweit der Staat selber auch Präventivmaßnahmen direkt im Fanmilieu mal machen könnte oder in Erwägung ziehen könnte. Ich glaube, der Staat hat sich da bislang immer eher als repressives Organ angesehen und das dann halt eben erst ermitteltätig wird, wenn es vermeintlich Fangewalt gegeben hat. Das ist ein Punkt, der bei der Frage ist denn, dass hier eine verhältnismäßige Regelung ausgleichend auch zu berücksichtigen wäre. Nichts desto weniger ist es natürlich schon so, wenn man sich jetzt diese Spiele wegdenkt, dann würde es mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit tatsächlich auch nicht dazu kommen, dass sich Fangruppen in der Stadt prügeln. Ironie des Schicksals. Ausgerechnet an dem Tag, an dem die Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts verkündet wurde, gab es anlässlich des Spiels Köln gegen HSV oder HSV gegen Köln.
HSV gegen Köln.
HSV gegen Köln. Gab es einen Fan-Übergriff von HSV Fans auf Kölner Fans in der Stadt. Also auch eine sehr unschöne Gewalthandlung, die dann auch noch so ein bisschen so diesen Zweck dann hat, Quad Era Demonstrandum, dann da seht ihr es doch, was da passiert. Aber ja, aber tatsächlich der Verein oder das, was dort in der Stadt geschieht, das ist im Prinzip die Möglichkeiten des Vereins entzogen, darauf Einfluss zu nehmen. Das ist also dann wirklich eine reine Kausalitätsbezogene Haftung, die rein darauf abstellt, dass der Verein oder die Bundesliga mit den Spielen wahnsinnig viel Geld verdient.
Vielleicht hat es so ein paar Anmerkungen. Zunächst das mit der Kostenfolge. Es ist eine exante Betrachtung. Also Juristen nennen das so. Es geht aus dem Wortlaut ganz klar vor, es wird abgerechnet, was man erforderlich hält. Also es wird nicht gesagt so und da müssten Sie jetzt in die Herbertstraße sieben und da mal aufräumen und das waren 20 Leute und deshalb kostet das so und so so viel, sondern es ist eine Einschätzung. Und damit kann man natürlich gnadenlos falsch liegen oder eben sehr, sehr richtig. Aber es ist eben eine Einschätzung vorher. Was du vorhin gesagt hast, Max, mit der Kausalität, da ist natürlich was dran, aber es gibt halt zwei Argumentationslinien. Die eine ist, naja, die DFL oder die Vereine, wie auch immer, sind Veranstalter. Und wenn wir uns das jetzt mal wegdenken würden, ohne Spiel gäbe es eben diese Ausschreitungen wahrscheinlich nicht. Auch wenn sie selbst sind, aber das gäbe sie wahrscheinlich nicht. Total augenscheinliches Gegenargument. Ja, aber das ist halt Handeln Dritter. Dafür sind die Vereine nicht verantwortlich. Sonst könnte man auch sagen, also Hitlers Mutter ist für den Zweiten Weltkrieg verantwortlich. Also das passt einfach nicht. Und genau deshalb stimm ich Fabian da auch zu, mit der Verhältnismäßigkeit, was ja auch alle anerkennen mit den Fanprojekten und so weiter. Das läuft dann ein bisschen aus dem Ruder. Nur Max T sagt, das Beispiel, das du jetzt aufgemacht hast mit Dortmund und Schalke, das ist in dieser ganzen Klage ja, und das hat Fabian zu Anfang auch gesagt, mal elegant umschifft worden. Denn wenn da Kartruhe sind, lieben die Berliner und kloppen sich mit meinen Stuttgartern oder so was, jetzt sagen wir mal hypothetisch, dann kommen noch ein paar Kaiserslautere dazu, weil es ja so schön ist. Ja, das ist aber alles unter der DFL. Also kann man sagen, es ist nicht der einzelne Verein, aber wir reden, kann die Politik sagen, wir reden ja jetzt mit der DFL. Und deshalb ist eigentlich dieses Urteil, es ist mein Bauchgefühl, es würde mich interessieren, was ihr dazu denkt, aber dieses Urteil könnte es einfach, es verschiebt die Verhandlungsmasse. Es verschiebt die Verhandlungsmasse, so dass die Politik jetzt sagen können, wir könnten euch ja zur Kasse bitten und jetzt schaut mal. Ja, also gerade auch ihr liebe DFL.
Ich bin da noch so ein bisschen unentschlossen. Ich glaube, nach den ersten Reaktionen, also es gab natürlich schon Innenministerinnen und Innenminister oder in einem Fall war es eine Senatorin in Berlin, die gesagt haben, nee, wir wollen das jetzt erstmal nicht. Liebe Vereine, beruhigt euch, liebe Fans. Ich bin euer Freund, ich bin doch selber hauhe bis ewig und so weiter. Und natürlich hat auch Joachim Herrmann, der hat gesagt, ja, also jetzt holen wir erstmal alle Vereine zusammen, aber eben auch die der dritten Liga. Deswegen auch nochmal dieser O-Ton, wo er dann eben ja sich auf den eigentlich DFB-Bereich des Fußballs bezieht und nicht den DFL-Bereich. Und wenn man jetzt die Verstrückung von Politik und Fußball sich anguckt, Edmund Stolber als im Aufsichtsrat oder im Vereinsbeirat vom FC Bayern sitzender und lange eben auch im Verein engagierter Mensch, ob der jetzt seinem armen FC Bayern das aufbürdet, dass der da ein paar Millionen zahlen muss, das ist nicht unbedingt sicher. Ich glaube aber, dass diese Grundsatzentscheidung, die es ja logischerweise ist, aber schon über den Fußball hinaus wirken könnte. Und da frage ich mich eben als Nichtjurist, ob es, also ich habe auch gelesen die Einschätzung in einem Artikel, das sei ein Dammbruch. Und dann wurden dann weitere gewinnorientierte Veranstaltungen genannt, die eben Mehrkosten bei Polizei verursachen. Also zum Beispiel Marathonveranstaltungen, Weihnachtsmärkte wurden da genannt, viele andere. Die Fanvertreter von unsere Kurve haben da auch Beispiele gebracht. Natürlich das Oktoberfest, aber auch Beispiele, die schwerer zu verargumentieren sind, wie der Kölner Karneval und das alles finde ich sind schon legitime Fragen, was das quasi verändern könnte und ob man da nicht in einem guten Willen heraus, ich finde es durchaus richtig, beim sehr, sehr reichen Fußball mal nachzufragen, ob er sich genügend um seine Probleme kümmert. Das ist nämlich das eigentliche, die eigentliche Frage ist doch, macht ihr genug Fanarbeit und da kann man nämlich auch sehr gut die Argumentation verfolgen. Also so wirklich mehr geworden ist das nicht in den letzten Jahren und die Vereine haben sich eher eigentlich darauf zurückgezogen, alle Fans, die eine Pyro-Fackel hochzuhalten, als sind nicht unsere Fans, sind die Chaoten und Krawallmacher zu bezeichnen und sich nicht darum zu kümmern, was könnte man vielleicht tun. Pyro, wenn sie wahrscheinlich weiter hochheben, aber um sie von anderen Dingen fernzuhalten. Und diese Frage stelle ich mir, ob das wirklich so ist, so wie es auch manche Fanvertreterinnen und Vertreter prophezeit haben. Jetzt wird quasi auf etwas, was verfassungsrechtlich gesichert ist, nämlich ein Sicherheitsempfinden, ein Gewaltmonopol, das beim Staat liegt. Jetzt wird da auf einmal ein Preiszettel drauf gepackt und das wird zwar Veranstaltungen nie zum Konkurs bringen können, weil da hätte es eben die erdrossende Wirkung, da wäre es nicht zulässig. Andererseits ist es ja aber auch nur noch vielleicht dann ein paar Gesetzesänderungen davon entfernt, dass man sich das zu ganz verschiedenen Dingen zu eigen machen könnte, je nachdem, welche Regierung dann vielleicht auch gerade am Zuge ist. Also Fabian, das ist jetzt die ganz große Frage, die ich hier gerade aufmache. Aber wie denkst du rund um diese Dammbruchproblematik?
Genau, Dammbruch oder Pandora's Box wird geöffnet. Ich war selbst einer von denen, hab unter anderem im Interview mit Zeit Online auch das Thema Weihnachtsmärkte, Marathon-Veranstaltungen, Oktoberfest angeschnitten. Das sind ja nach dem Maßstab dieser Bremer Vorschrift, die sagt, also mehr als 5000 Personen ist dann eine Veranstaltung, die hier in den Anwendungsbereich fällt und gewinnorientiert muss sie auch sein. Das sind dann alles Veranstaltungen, die da reinfallen. Und es mag zwar sein, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt so ein Regulativ da irgendwie einzieht mit der erdrosselnden Wirkung, aber auch da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was ist denn erdrosselnd und was ist nicht mehr erdrosselnd? Also ja, ein Weihnachtsmarkt, der wird möglicherweise sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr hart kalkulieren und ist schon bei einer halbwegs geringen Belastung mit der Übernahme von Polizeikosten dann möglicherweise nicht mehr rentabel. Und es wird sich insofern überlegen, ob sich das alles noch lohnt. Aber ein Weihnachtsmarkt, muss man natürlich auch ganz ehrlich sagen, ist seit den jüngeren und auch nicht mehr so jüngeren Vorfällen, wie jetzt jüngst zum Beispiel Magdeburg, ist natürlich dann vor dem Hintergrund auch eine Hochrisikoveranstaltung. Und das kann man sich natürlich für jede weitere Veranstaltung, bei der massenhaft Leute kommen, dann auch vorstellen. Wie wird dann künftig damit verfahren, wenn dann erhöhtes Polizeiaufruhr oder erhöhtes Sicherungsmaßnahmen vorgenommen wird. Ich hab auch noch mal geguckt bei den Regionalligisten übrigens, also noch unter der dritten Liga, da gibt es auch einige Betroffene. Meppen hat zum Beispiel im Zuschnäuerschnitt mehr als 6.000 in dieser Saison. Die sind auch mit dabei dann. In der Regionalliga Nordost sind es Jena, Halle, Lok Leipzig und Erfurt, die alle über 5.000 haben. Und in der Regionalliga Südwest unter anderem Kikas Offenbach mit durchschnittlich 7.000. Also die können sich das schlicht gar nicht leisten. Würde ich mal jetzt prognostizieren, da noch zusätzlich für Polizeikosten bezahlen zu müssen. Weil die haben es alle nicht so wahnsinnig dicke, sondern kalkulieren eben auch sehr hart, um ihren Kader finanzieren zu können, um sich den Stadionbetrieb leistens zu können und so weiter. Ja, insofern, für mich sieht das Ganze irgendwie schon immer noch so ein bisschen aus, als hätte man jetzt dadurch, dass die DFL hier beteiligt ist und dadurch, dass es um den professionellen Fußball geht und man weiß, da wird viel Geld umgesetzt, so ein bisschen so eine Lex-DFL hier geschaffen. Ich will aber das gleich noch ein bisschen relativieren, weil ich meine, Entscheidungen des Bundesverfassungsgerichts haben natürlich schon auch immer eine politische Dimension. Und auch wenn Stefan Habert da versucht, das so ein bisschen zu relativieren. Aber dass es nun, dass nun so entschieden wurde oder dass überhaupt die Geschichte ihren Verlauf so genommen hat, liegt natürlich möglicherweise auch ein bisschen daran, dass eine DFL, die dann möglicherweise sagt, ja, aber das sind ja eigentlich Kosten, die die Allgemeinheit tragen muss, unter anderem auch, weil der Fußball eben allgemein gut ist, weil alle irgendwie davon profitieren. Weil zum Beispiel auch bei Europameisterschaften, des Land und die jeweiligen Ausrichterstädte, da waren sie nicht viel Geld mit verdient. Wenn man sich dann aber auf der anderen Seite hinstellt und fordert, vielleicht sogar durch Gesetzgebung, dass die Verwertung, die Verwertungsrechte an dem Fußball ausschließlich einem Veranstalter wie der DFL oder anderen Veranstalter dazustehen sollen, finde ich, preist sich das so ein bisschen und das gibt ein unschönes Bild, was sicherlich auch maßgeblich dazu beiträgt, dass dann die Allgemeinheit irgendwie sagt, naja, aber ihr steckt euch sozusagen die ganzen Verdienste, die ganzen Einkünfte an den Veranstaltungen in die Tasche und wir müssen aber dafür sorgen, dass ihr sie durchführen könnt.
Wenn ich jetzt vielleicht noch mal kurz an das Urteil selbst oder die Entscheidung selbst eingehe. Die zugrundeliegende Vorschrift, die spricht ja von zu erwartenden Gewalthandlungen. Also wir müssen uns vielleicht kurz auch mal vor Augen führen, dass ja auch beim normalen Fußballspiel schon gewisser Polizeipräsenz da ist und auch das kostet. Und ich glaube, in dem zugrundeliegenden Fall waren es 150 gegenüber 900 irgendwas. Und das steht ja überhaupt nicht in Frage. Das will ja auch, also das wird ja überhaupt nicht diskutiert. Das ist in der Vorschrift nicht zum Ausdruck gekommen. Von daher mach ich mal ein bisschen ein Fragezeichen dran. Also wir dürfen nicht so tun, als sei das jetzt der Regelfall. Bei allen Schwierigkeiten, die es über die Einschätzung, stimm ich völlig überein. Das ist eine kurze Black Box. Aber wir reden ja schon so ein bisschen vom Ausnahmefall zur Regel. Wir reden nicht darum, dass generell alle Fußballspiele jedenfalls jetzt zur Kasse gebeten werden sollen. Was ich dann aber interessant finde, und das sind diese Beispiele, die vorhin auch kamen. Wir können uns mal überlegen, wo haben wir denn in Deutschland potenziell Veranstaltungen mit über 5.000 Leuten, wo regel- und erfahrungsgemäß Gewalthandlungen zu erwarten sind. Also die Love Parade ist es jedenfalls eher nicht. Und da kommen wir dann zu dem unschönen Gedanken, der sich genau mit dem deckt, was Fabian vorgesagt hat. Das sieht schon sehr klar so aus, als wäre das einfach für den Fußball geschaffen worden. Und ich bin, sind ja offen für Gegenbeispiele, aber ich sichere sie so nicht.
Das ist ja auch tatsächlich das, also auch ein Weihnachtsmarkt, da ist ja nicht mit einer Gefahr zu rechnen. Und vor allem der Begriff der Sicherheit ist ja logischerweise ein sehr subjektiver und auch juristisch kein eindeutig zu fassender. Und das alles ist ja die Vorbedingung für Gebühren, die überhaupt erhoben werden können. Und da hätte man ja auch sehr gut argumentieren können. Und das hat ja auch die DFL in Teilen getan, dass ja Fußball im Stadion etwas sehr Sicheres ist. Und vielleicht ist es dann doch nochmal wichtig, diesen Punkt hier zu machen. Es gibt die Zahlen des ZIS, der Zentralen Informationsstelle für Sport. Die sind schon sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen, denn da wird eher höher gerechnet als niedrig gerechnet. Und jeder durch eigenes Pfefferspray verletzte Polizist kommt auch in der Statistik. Das heißt, es sind schon Zahlen, die eher von oben kommen als von unten, würde ich jetzt zumindest mal behaupten. Und die haben eben die Zahlen für 2023, 2024 präsentiert. Sie haben 28 Millionen Fans in den Stadien der ersten drei Ligen und der fünf Regionalligen gehabt. Das waren insgesamt über 2600 Spiele. Kurze Klammer, man rechnet bei den Hochrisikospielen bei einer Zahl von zwischen 65 bis 120, die es pro Jahr geben könnte. Das setzt das nochmal in Relation, was du gerade gesagt hast, Philipp. Es geht nicht bei weitem, nicht um alle Spiele. Dieses ZDS, das eben wie gesagt eher höhere Zahlen ansetzt, rechnet mit gewaltbereiten Fans in den ersten drei Ligen 13.800. Es gab Straftaten. Ich hab das jetzt immer umgerechnet, weil die einzelnen Zahlen, die sagen einem nichts. Also Straftaten. Es gibt ungefähr eine Straftat und das kann logischerweise sehr viel sein, pro 3.900 Fans. Verletzte, es gibt einen Verletzten oder eine Verletzte pro ungefähr 21.000 Zuschauern. Ordnungswidrigkeiten, da ist auch jeder Wildpinkler mit dabei, ohne dass ich sagen will, dass es cool ist, deswegen. Eins pro 10.000 Zuschauern und Stadionverbote, die ausgesprochen werden. Das heißt, hier ist man jemandem habhaft geworden, konnte ihn identifizieren und verband ihn dann aus den deutschen Stadien eins pro 77.000 Zuschauern. Und ich will damit nichts rechtsfertigen. Ich will nichts kleinreden. Ich will aber die Verhältnismäßigkeit klar machen, weil ich glaube, dass sich hier das subjektive Sicherheitsempfinden von denjenigen, die oft in Stadien sind und jenenjenigen, die nicht in Stadien sind, grotesk unterscheidet. Und da spielen auch Medienberichterstattung und ja, da spielen viele Aspekte eine Rolle. Aber da hätte man ja doch eigentlich, Fabian, auch die Argumentation fangen können. Also bei solchen Zahlen, wie viel Risiko gibt es denn dann wirklich bei diesen Hochrisiko-Spielen? Und ist es nicht vielleicht generell, wenn wir eh schon nicht wissen, wie es zu dieser Einschätzung kommt, rot, gelb, grün, wann die Ampel da umschaltet auf Hochrisiko? Aber gibt es Gesellschaftsbereiche, also ist das quasi viel? Wie definiert man Sicherheit juristisch?
Ehrlich gesagt, die Frage kann ich nicht beantworten. Ich kann mir auch, ich kann letztlich auch nicht ganz beantworten, wie es zu diesen Zahlen kommt. Aber fragt beispielsweise mal Strafrechtskollegen, welche Straftaten dann überhaupt eigentlich in diese Statistik einfließen. Also ich hab jetzt wirklich nur vage, ich bin kein Strafrechtler, aber der Landfriedensbruch, der ist ja ein Tatbestand, der möglicherweise dann schon erfüllt ist, wenn man sich in einer Gruppierung aufhält, die Gewalthandlungen außerhalb des Stadionbereichs ausübt, aber wo man selber jetzt nicht auch unmittelbar beteiligt ist, kann man möglicherweise relativ schnell dort in diese Statistik reinkommen und dadurch sich dann auch die Zahlen exorbitant erhöhen. Aber ja, also die Einschätzung nochmal, wir hatten das ja vorhin schon besprochen, die Einschätzung anhand der Zahlen und anhand dessen, was in der Vergangenheit geschehen ist, vorzunehmen, ist schwierig. Und soweit jedenfalls man diese Einschätzung den Behörden überlässt, muss man einfach damit rechnen, dass diese im Zweifel immer das Risiko zu hoch einschätzen. Also es tatsächlich ist, übrigens warum auch, weil sie natürlich im Zweifel dann später rechtfertigen müssen, warum sie dann Gewaltmaßnahmen, die dann entstanden sind, nicht verhindern konnten. Und da ist dann, das ist natürlich auch eine hochpolitische Geschichte, weil da können dann im Zweifel innerhalb der Behörden dann irgendwie auch mal Köpfe rollen. Und da möchte natürlich keiner derjenige sein, der da am Kreuz vorher steht, dann insbesondere vielleicht auch noch öffentlich. Und wird dann eben im Zweifel lieber einfach auf das Motto setzen, Vorsicht ist die Mutter der Porzellankiste.
Und eigentlich möchte man das ja auch als Gesellschaft würde ich mal annehmen. Also das zum Beispiel bei den wirklich nicht schönen Bildern aus Hamburg, wo eben die Hamburg-Fans auf Rentner und ein Kind soll auch mit dabei gewesen sein, eingeprügelt haben auf St. Pauli, dass das sich so schnell beruhigt hat, hatte ganz sicher auch damit zu tun, dass nach allem, was ich gehört habe, die Polizei rundert schafft oder zumindest ein kleiner Einsatztrupp, der war in der Straße nebenan, die sind dazwischen gegangen und dann war das nach einer Minute vorbei. Und das ist ja das, was wir wollen. Wir wollen ja Sicherheit und wir wollen, dass wenn es mal knallt, schlimm genug, dass es knallt, aber so ist es leider, wird sich nie ganz verhindern lassen, dann wollen wir ja auch Sicherheit haben und dafür ist die Polizei da. Aber gleichzeitig empfindet man ja auch Philipp als Fußballfan bzw. es ist, glaube ich, nicht nur ein subjektives Empfinden, sondern es lässt sich auch mit Zahlen belegen, dass aber gerade weil Fußballfans so ein gutes Opfer sind, weil sie die bösen Buben sind, in Anführungszeichen, es ist sehr einfach ein Bild zu zeichnen von eben den Chaoten, die Innenstädte in Schutt und Asche legen, so dass es eben sogar bei reflektierten Menschen dann sich verfängt in den Köpfen. Gerade deswegen erlebt man ja auch immer wieder, dass Fußballfans durchaus auch Versuchskaninchen sind für Einsatztaktiken, jetzt hat der zuständige Polizeischiff gewechselt und fährt mal einen härteren Kurs oder zum Beispiel im Rahmen der Europameisterschaft hatten wir auf einmal wirklich Grenzüberschreitungen der Polizei gegenüber der Gesellschaft, in dem Fall dann Fußballfans, die eben auch sehr kritisch zu sehen waren. Wir haben Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die immer wieder gerne im Kontext des Fußballs ausprobiert werden wollen, unter anderem auch bei der EM 2024, wo jeder Ticketinhaber und man kam nur über die EM-App ins Stadion. Der Aufenthalt dort jedes Ticketinhabers war zwar anonymisiert, aber er war sichtbar für die Einsatzzentralen. Das wurde einfach so nebenher mal berichtet in einem Bericht des Bayerischen Rundfunks. Und das ist ja die Ebene, die glaube ich dann zum Beispiel Fanvertreter haben, wie unsere Kurve, die dann auch in ihrem Statement zu hören sind. Ich spiele das noch mal kurz ein, wie jetzt dann die Lage der Nation darauf reagiert hat. Es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass ich jetzt Philipp Banzer und Ulf Burma hier so raushebe. Ich habe auch noch andere O-Töne, aber die passen immer am besten, um zu zeigen, wie denken Menschen darüber, die nicht so tief im Fußball sind. Und Philipp, du darfst dann gerne mal ihnen das erklären, was sie nicht verstanden haben.
Also Fanorganisationen reagieren entsetzt auf dieses Urteil. Sie sehen in dieser Entscheidung ein Präzedenzfall und ein Freifahrtschein für eine immer aggressive und martialische auftretende Polizei. Freifahrtschein, warum den Zusammenhang verstehe ich nicht. Also nur weil die Polizei aus einer anderen Quelle bezahlt wird, tritt sich martialischer auf. Ich habe das auch nicht so ganz verstanden. Also das erschließt sich mir so spontan nicht.
Da tue ich mich jetzt auch ein bisschen schwer. Also ich will ganz ehrlich sein, denn das staatliche, also vielleicht muss man auch mal klarstellen, am staatlichen Gewaltmonopol ändert sich gar nichts. Am staatlichen Auftrag ändert sich gar nichts. Worüber man mal reden könnte oder da müsste man vielleicht mal eine Evaluation starten, keine Ahnung, ob sich, wenn die Polizei-Präsidenten drei Jahre lang sich gewissermaßen Geld ganz oder teilweise wiederholen können, ob sich dann tatsächlich was an ihrem Verhalten ändert. Das können wir dann gerne mal empirisch untersuchen, aber eigentlich ändert, also mich überzeugt das, also tut mir leid, wenn ich dich da enttäuschen muss, gar nicht. Da würde ich dich, mich deinen Podcast-Kollegen mal anschließen.
Ja, ich glaube die Korsalkette, dass es jetzt wegen dieser Entscheidung martialischer würde, das halte ich auch für falsch. Ich glaube aber, das ist nicht das, was die Fans sagen wollten. Ich glaube die Fans wollten sagen, wir erleben jetzt schon, dass es immer martialischer wird, dass wir im Zweifel eher zwei Wasserwerfer gegen uns positioniert sind als einen Wasserwerfer. Dass wir zum Teil Bereitschaftspolizistinnen und Polizisten aus anderen Bundesländern haben, die dann für Sicherheit sorgen sollen, bei denen das Gefühl der Unsicherheit wächst und das manchmal auch aus guten Gründen. Es gibt auch Fälle von Polizeigewalt, ohne dass sich das eine mit dem anderen gleichsetzen möchte, aber das eine wird strafrechtlich viel weniger verfolgt als das andere. Und dass quasi diese Tendenz, die die Fans wahrnehmen, die ich in Teilen auch unterstützen würde, ich hab's rund um im Vorfeld der EM fand ich, war das durchaus zu beobachten, dass das unterstützt wird, wenn es jetzt auch noch gezahlt wird. Ich glaube, das ist das, was Sie sagen wollen.
Okay, gut. Aber ganz kurz dazu, da sind wir wieder auf der politischen Ebene. Ich meine, dass diese Entscheidung als Dammbruch, ich meine, dass das Gericht sagt, man darf es so machen, aber wir sagen nicht, man soll es so machen. Und dann das Gericht als Dammbruch, das spricht nur Recht. Also sagt, okay, das ist nach geltender Rechtslage, aber mehr sagen wir dazu auch nicht. Und das ist da deshalb nicht das Dammbruch-Argument ein bisschen schwierig an dieser Stelle. Das soll es uns verfassungsrecht sagen. Soll es dann sagen, wir machen jetzt eine andere Meinung oder irgendwas juristisch schwerer haltbares. Näsien scheinen ja nur diesen Fall. Aber da sehe ich jetzt als Hochschullehrer drauf und nicht als jemand, der das dann praktisch begleitet. Aber ich glaube, ich habe Fabian gerade so ein bisschen abgeschnitten.
Gar nicht. Ich will nur tatsächlich da auch noch was zu einwerfen. Ich sehe das ganz ähnlich wie du, Max. Weil ich glaube auch, dass die Fans nicht damit meinen, dass jetzt die Polizei diese Entscheidung zum Anlass nimmt, dann dann mal ordentlich auf die Fresse zu hauen. Aber dass natürlich ein besonderes Maß an Polizeiaufgebot und besondere Einsatzszenarien auch Situationen zuspitzen können. Und damit vielleicht dann eben auch Gewalt sozusagen mitbegründend sind, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Ich kann mich zum Beispiel erinnern, ich hab früher in der Nähe von Görlitzer Bahnhof hier in Berlin gewohnt, in der Pücklerstraße und da war zum 1. Mai war da immer richtig Bambule. Und ich konnte das, konnte ich von der WG, die ich da hatte, konnte ich das sogar von der Terrasse aus alles sehen, was da passierte. Da brannten auch Autos und so weiter. Und ich erinnere mich, dass ich einmal, da kam ich irgendwie nach Hause zurück, bieg um die Ecke und plötzlich kommt mir ein Wasserwerfer entgegen. Und das ist schon ein komisches Gefühl, weil so ein Wasserwerfer ist ein richtig fettes Ding. Das sieht aus wie ein Panzer. Und wenig später war dann irgendwie noch eine Polizeisperre, bei der ich dann nachweisen musste, dass ich da wohne und da Vorlage meines Ausweises und so. Und ich will jetzt sagen, das hat mich jetzt alles nicht nachhaltig belastet, aber es ist ein komisches Gefühl. Und da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das auch für Fans, die gar keine Absichten in Richtung Gewalt haben, dass das vielleicht auch schon irgendwo kritisch, berechtigterweise kritisch wahrgenommen wird, wenn man dann vielleicht plötzlich eingekesselt ist oder wenn dann so eine Gerätschaften da auffahren. So verstehe ich die Fan-Äußerungen und ich glaube, dass da im Lage der Nation tatsächlich das nicht ganz richtig gewürdigt hat.
Ja, aber da muss ich gleich mal wieder reden. Die würden aber trotzdem stehen, die Wasserwerfer. Also die Gefahr, die ich sehe, ist, dass die Politik das jetzt gewissermaßen als Freibrief nehmen könnte und nicht als Freibrief, aber jetzt so, ha, jetzt, also wir können's, jetzt machen wir's auch. Und wir haben ja auch jetzt bald Wahlen, bei denen es ja auch immer einiges gibt, die nächste Landtagswahl in Bayern kommt auch. Max, du weißt immer, was dann hier passiert. Aber die würden da doch trotzdem stehen. Also diese Kausalkette aus Urteil und jetzt, also die sieht halt nicht.
Aber glaubst du, es ist wahrscheinlicher geworden, dass vielleicht jetzt mal bei einem Spiel kein Wasser war, versteht, bei einem Hochrisikospiel. Also dass wir die Spirale vielleicht zurückdrehen. Ja und darum geht's, glaube ich. Dass quasi damit jetzt klar ist, es wird nicht mehr zurückgehen hinter den Standard, der jetzt herrscht und den kann man aus sehr, sehr guten kritisieren. Für den gibt es auch gute Gründe, dass es ihn gibt. Aber ich glaube, das ist das, was gemeint ist. Es wird jetzt nicht zurückgehen. Es wird nicht zu weniger Polizeipräsenz führen, sondern tendenziell und das erscheint mir schon relativ logisch, eher zu mehr, weil es jetzt ein bisschen einfacher zu verargumentieren ist und auch zu entscheiden. Ich meine, all die Arbeitsstunden, die da geleistet werden, die Überstunden, die Polizistinnen und Polizisten aufbauen, das ist ja völlig grotesk. Die sind ja auch völlig underequipped und so weiter und so fort. Obwohl man das beim Fußball nicht so sieht, weil da hast du immer das neueste Wasserwerferding stehen. Das ist ja auch ein guter Grund, etwas anzuschaffen. Und genau da sind wir in der Thematik. Und ich glaube darum geht es, dass man eine durchaus... Aufrüstung ist ein schwieriges Wort, weil es sehr martialisch klingt, aber eine sehr, sehr große erhöhte Präsenz von Polizeigerätschaften und auch Personen rund um Fußballfans, Fußballspiele wahrnimmt in den letzten Jahren. Und dass das jetzt noch mal zurückgehen würde und es gibt ja auch durchaus auch wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen, die davon ausgehen, eine geringere Polizeipräsenz kann. Sie muss nicht, aber sie kann auch zu einem erhöhten Sicherheitsgefühl führen und auch mit einer geringeren Polizeipräsenz können auch Fußballspiele sicher durchgeführt werden. Der Zugang zu dieser Welt wird ja ein bisschen schwerer gemacht, wenn man es jetzt bezahlt bekommt.
Und jetzt muss man ja auch ganz klar sagen, also dieser Rechtsweg, der hinter den Beteiligten liegt, der hatte ja ein Ergebnis, das war Hopp oder Top. Das heißt also, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht eine andere Auffassung gewesen wäre, hätte das dazu geführt, dass Land Bremen und gegebenenfalls welche, die da nachziehen, gar keine Gebühren für mehr Einsatz hätten verlangen können. Und jetzt können sie es aber und dann ist doch die Rechnung eigentlich ganz einfach. Die sagen sich, naja, so einen Wasserwerfer kriege ich vielleicht auf jeden Fall abgerechnet und dann stelle ich doch vielleicht noch mal einen zweiten dazu. Und wenn ich den am Ende nicht abgerechnet kriege, weil mir dann im Verwaltungsverfahren dann doch rechtlich dabeise vorgehalten wird, das war jetzt aber too much, dann habe ich doch zumindest irgendwie die Hälfte meiner Einsatzkosten raus. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass diese Kalkulationsgrundlage eben dann doch dazu führt, dass ich im Zweifel da bei den Maßnahmen den Maßstab ein bisschen lockerer anlege.
Ja, das ist nicht. Ja, da kann man schwer was dagegen sagen. Und Maxi, ich stimme auch dir zu, dass die Entscheidung passt natürlich so in den generellen gesellschaftlichen Flow, Sicherheitsgefühl und so weiter und so fort. Und das Gericht hat eben nicht die Bremse reingehauen und zu sagen, so geht es jetzt aber nicht. Nur ist das vielleicht auch eine Wahrnehmung an die Gerichte oder in dem Fall das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und das sieht man in vielen, vielen Bereichen, sind das Erwartungen, die dann vielleicht schief oder irgendwie überzogen sind. Weil wie gesagt, ich dreh mich so ein bisschen im Kreis. Wie gesagt, die sagen nur, dass man darf.
Eigentlich soll das Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht diesem Flock einhauen, sondern es soll nur diesen Fall beurteilen.
Genau. Und ich stimme dir zu, das Rad werden wir nicht zurückdrehen, aber das hätte eigentlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch nur, also wenn sie es getan hätten, dann hätten sie aber mit ganz vielen anderen Sachen wohl sich auf glattes Eis begeben. Also ich bleibe dabei, es ist halt eine politische Frage und da wird es halt interessant.
Und es wird vor allem eher interessant in der Berichterstattung über ein solches Urteil. Ich finde da sind wir jetzt nämlich gerade beim springenden Punkt. Ich habe das vorhin schon mal in einem Nebensatz erwähnt, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass es sehr einfach ist, über dieses Urteil zu sprechen und sich dazu eine Meinung zu bilden, aber sehr sehr schwer ist, über die dahinter liegenden Bewegungen in unserer Gesellschaft zu sprechen. Also eben das, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe. Es sind überdurchschnittlich Männer, die Gewalttaten rund um den Fußball, aber eben nicht nur im Fußball vollführen. Alkohol spielt eine ganz ganz wichtige Rolle, auch andere Drogen bei der BG und dieser Straftaten. Und wir sehen eine zunehmende Radikalisierung und die sehen wir eben nicht nur im Fußball. Wir haben das immer wieder, wenn sich Nazis im Kurven durchsetzen und äußern, dass wir dann immer wieder an den Punkt kommen, dass wir sagen, ja wie soll der Fußball auch einer gesellschaftlichen Gesamtentwicklung, wo manche jetzt aus ihren Löchern kommen und Dinge sagen, die nicht sagbar waren noch vor ein paar Jahren, wie soll der Fußball sich dem entgegenstellen? Fabian, ist das nicht eigentlich die Diskussion, die man führen müsste? Denn auch allein monetär gesehen bezahlt die Gesellschaft ja so oder so. Entweder bezahlt die Gesellschaft alle Polizeieinsätze, auch bei Hochrisikospielen. Dann wird es auf die Schultern aller verteilt. Oder wir haben eben die Fußballvereine, die ihr Geld woher bekommen? Über Sponsoren und über TV-Gelder, was übrigens auch nach meinem Wissen nach Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dieses Landes bezahlen. Also es läuft nur einen anderen Weg. Plus wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt noch ein bisschen leichter, mehr auszugeben auf Seiten der Polizei, weil man es eben wiederbekommt, die gerade eben geführte Diskussion. Also sprich, am Ende ist diese Zufriedenheit, die manche nicht Fußballfans haben. Endlich werden die mal zur Kasse geboten. Mir scheint das so ein bisschen ein Druckschluss zu sein. Und auch die eigentlich interessante Debatte, was ist denn eigentlich gesamtgesellschaftlich vielleicht zu erkennen an diesem Problem im Fußball, die wird dadurch so ein bisschen überlagert.
Ja, also die Gedanken hab ich mir natürlich auch gemacht und es wäre wahrscheinlich ein Weg gewesen, dass man sich bei Zeiten und wie gesagt diese Diskussion darum wäre, da die Kosten zu tragen hat, die ist ja schon älter als zehn Jahre, dass man sich vielleicht bei Zeiten unter den sogenannten Stakeholdern Gedanken darüber gemacht hätte, wie man in Ansehung dieser dann doch ja teilweise schon auch notwendigen Kosten, wie man die umlegt und wie man eine Lösung dafür findet, dass sagen wir mal, sich alle Beteiligten, die begünstigt sind oder darunter leiden, irgendwo wohlfühlen. Also Stichwort, irgendein Fonds. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr so gut dran erinnern, ob diese Vorschläge schon mal tatsächlich auf dem Tisch waren oder wie die wieder behandelt wurden. Aber natürlich könnte man sich überlegen, ob nicht die Allgemeinheit plus die DFL beziehungsweise die beteiligten Vereine einfach einen Topf dafür machen, dass man solche Einsätze in Zukunft bezahlen kann.
Und wenn man teammarktwert ist, dann muss man ein bisschen mehr zahlen, wenn man Fans hat. Da bewegen wir uns gleich auf die nächste Debatte zu.
Also eine Fondslösung wurde durchaus vorgeschlagen von Ulrich Meurer direkt nach der Urteilsverkündung. Er meinte damit aber ein Fonds innerhalb der DFL, denn das ist jetzt noch so ein Nebenthema, das haben wir ausgespart, das ja aktuell jetzt erstmal nur Werder Bremen betrifft, aber eben es jetzt wahrscheinlich auch sein kann, dass es auch in anderen Bundesländern kommt, aber vielleicht ja auch in Bundesländern, die gar keinen Bundesligisten haben oder weniger Hochrisikospiele und dann eben die Frage ist, zahlt es die Gemeinschaft der DFL-Vereine oder wird da jeder einzelne Verein von der DFL dann wiederum zur Kasse gebeten? Aber das ist eine Diskussion, die sollen die führen. Also das ist, ich finde, das muss nicht unsere sein. Aber ist es nicht interessant, dass wir es eigentlich nicht schaffen, auf das Größerliegende zu blicken, weil es da auch keine klaren, also weil die Befunde schwieriger zu treffen sind und vor allem Gegenmaßnahmen auch schwieriger sind. Also wie willst du männlich geprägte Gewalt aus der Gesellschaft kriegen? Da habe ich jetzt natürlich auch kein Rezept. Aber eigentlich ist es doch auch ein Ergebnis dessen. Also die Fans nehmen Fußball zum Anlass, um sich zu prügeln. Und manchmal ist das vielleicht auch der Grund, warum sie sich prügeln. Manchmal wollen sie sich aber vielleicht auch einfach nur prügeln. Und müsste man nicht die Frage stellen, wie man mit solchen Menschen in der Gesellschaft umgeht, wie man das vielleicht schafft, für die Allgemeinheit verträglicher zu machen und vielleicht auch manchen dazu zu bringen, das nicht zu tun. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das mit diesen Polizeikosten urteilt. Also die Chaoten werden nicht aufhören, sich jetzt zu prügeln.
Leider. Ja, das stimmt. Ich kann mich aber daran erinnern, dass ich in meinem Studium das Wahlfach Kriminologie hatte. Und da war das schon ein Thema. Und als ich studiert habe, war es aber auch schon 20 Jahre vorher ein Thema gewesen, dass die Fangewalt eben einen soziologischen Aspekt hat und ein ganz vielschichtiges Thema ist. Also klassischerweise könnte man ja sagen, naja, dann sollen die sich doch prügeln. Und man fühlt sie dann irgendwie auf ein eingehegtes Feld. Und da können sie dann machen, was sie wollen. Und wer zuschauen will, guckt sich das eben an. Oder ansonsten nicht, aber es betrifft dann die Allgemeinheit nicht. Nur so funktioniert das in der Praxis eben gar nicht. Und ja, wie gesagt, sucht man das Gespräch mit Fanforschern, mit Kriminologen, die sich um dieses Phänomen Gedanken machen. Und das schon seit Jahren wird man feststellen, dass es eben dafür keine Lösung gibt, die man am Reißbrett so entwerfen kann. Das ist, das gehört sozusagen auch zur Gesellschaft dazu, dass sich diese Form der Gewaltbereitschaft auf diese Art und Weise entladen. Und damit will ich sagen, ich hab da keine Lösung parat und ich hätte auch gewisse Zweifel, dass man jetzt auch einmal nach dieser Entscheidung so viel Kräfte mobilisieren kann, dass man das Problem innerhalb von zwei Jahren gelöst hat. Das glaube ich nicht.
Das wollte ich auch nicht ganz damit suggerieren. Philipp.
Ja, kann ich für dich hinzufügen. Ich meine, es ist einerseits ja fast schon, ich mach grad hier jetzt die Gänsefüße in dem Podcast, schön, dass sich das Ganze am Fußball entlädt. Das zeigt nämlich, was der Fußball für einen gesellschaftlichen Stellenwert haben. Dass diese Fragen dann halt anhand des Fußballs gestellt werden und diskutieren. Aber der Fußball kann sie halt nicht lösen. Und wir verwalten mit diesen Urteilen, mit den Polizeikosten und so weiter und so fort verwalten wir so ein bisschen den Mangel oder versuchen irgendwie flicken drauf zu machen auf gesellschaftliche Umstände. Und das werden wir hier nicht gelöst bekommen. Leider.
Wir drei sowieso nicht. Bei allem guten Willen. Aber und ich weiß ja auch, dass es auch super langweilig auch immer auf diese großen Themen zu kommen, für die es keine einfache Lösung gibt. Aber also es ist schon interessant zu sehen, dass es im Kleinen dann doch immer scheinbar pragmatische Lösungen gibt. Also zum Beispiel kennzeichnet ein Hochrisikospiel auch, dass es im Stadion oft nur alkoholfreies Bier gibt oder irgendwie niederprozentiges Bier. Löst das Problem nicht? Warum? Die Leute kommen schon vorher angeschossen rein und wer sich das teure Stadionbier kauft, der hat sowieso die Kontrolle über seinen Stadionbesuch verloren, wenn ihr mich fragt. Aber es ist ja interessant, dass hier eine Antwort auf Risiko und auf Gewalt ist und auf Übergriffe und auf Straftaten, Ordnungswidrigkeiten und so weiter und so fort. Wir schränken den Alkoholkonsum ein. Und dann endet aber hier die Diskussion. Und ich will jetzt, liebe Leute, ich will euch nicht das Bier wegnehmen. Bitte, bitte, ihr könnt die Fackeln wieder einpacken. Stellt euch nicht vor mein Haus. Das möchte ich nicht. Aber so eine grundsätzliche Diskussion könnte man schon drüber führen, was eben dann und da gibt es ja auch andere Stellschrauben. Zum Beispiel können wir sogar beim Fußball bleiben. Werbung für Alkohol im Fußball. Da hat sich ja schon mal was verändert. War noch in den 90ern anders als es jetzt ist und so weiter und so fort. Und ich finde es interessant, es ist erklärbar, sehr leicht erklärbar, warum diese Fragen nicht diskutiert werden, weil sie sind extrem komplex. Sie sind total unbequem und du musst den Leuten was wegnehmen. Das heißt, du bist quasi die Verkörperung der Grünen. Und das sage ich als jemand, der eben in dem Bundesland lebt, in dem niemand so schlimm ist wie die Grünen, wenn es zumindest nach Markus Söder geht. Aber eigentlich könnte es ja auch so weitergehen. Aber das ist eben leider hier auch nicht passiert.
Eine ganz konkrete Sache, die sich jetzt heraus ergeben kann. Dieses Urteil, das muss man auch sagen, betrifft der einzige Anwendungsfall dieses Urteils, es stand heute Werder Bremen. Und jetzt frage ich mich dran, wie geht denn jetzt Werder Bremen damit um? Eine ganz einfache Lösung wäre, die wir alle nicht wollen.
In die dritte Liege runtergehen.
Ich würde es nicht ganz so weit machen, aber ich hätte jetzt gesagt, aber nach dem wird es zwar auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anwenden können, aber die logische Vorgehensweise, man sagt, wir wollen jetzt diese in Zukunft, diese inzwischen sind es anscheinend über drei Millionen Euro, nicht zahlen bzw. wir wollen nicht, dass die DFL das von uns wiederholt. Also erstens müssen wir innerhalb der DFL dafür sorgen, nur sagen alle anderen 35 so, ja ich zuck grad meine Schultern hoch und die naheliegende Lösung wäre, dass jetzt keine Gästefans mit zugelassen werden bei Sachen, die problematisch sein könnten und das ist ja eine Konsequenz, mal ganz praktisch, wie nun wirklich keiner von uns will. Und ich rede jetzt ja nicht von Wolfsburg, das ist ja dieses absurde Beispiel, aber Hamburg-Fans, ja, finde ich ganz komplex.
Und vielleicht sind wir da gar nicht so weit von entfernt, denn Tarek Brauer, der Geschäftsführer für Personal und Organisation von Werder Bremen, der hat unter anderem im NDR das hier gesagt.
Jetzt im Liga-Verband und das ist meine Erwartungshaltung, werden wir Diskussionen führen müssen. Und zwar Diskussionen darum, dass Werder Bremen hier nicht allein ich die Zeche zahlen darf. Und meine Erwartungshaltung ist schon die, dass wir die Veranstalterrolle in Blick nehmen und dass wir das Verursacherprinzip in Blick nehmen. Denn es bleibt doch festzuhalten, dass die DFL mindestens eine Co-Veranstalterrolle hat. Und es bleibt auch festzuhalten, dass die Anhänger des Gastvereins durchaus dazu beitragen, dass ein Spiel ein Hochrisikospiel wird mit Kostenfolge. Und meine Erwartungshaltung ist, dass wir da nicht allein im Haftungsboot sitzen, sondern die DFL und der Gastverein mindestens genauso.
Also Philipp, als hättest du diesen O-Ton vorher schon...
Liebe Hörer, wir hatten das vorher nicht abgesprochen.
Wir hatten das vorher nicht abgesprochen. Aber genau, das sind die Diskussionen, die zu führen sind. Und das bringt mich eigentlich dann auch so ein bisschen zum Fazit oder zum Ausblick. Wir haben jetzt versucht zum Reisen, worum es hier geht, wie es dazu kam. Ich würde gern jetzt nochmal in aller Kürze eure Meinung zu diesem Urteil abfragen. Erstmal die Meinung, Dammbruch ja oder nein? Fabian, was würdest du sagen?
Vom Gefühl ehrlich gesagt eher nicht. Also Dammbruch in juristischer Hinsicht ja. In der Praxis könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass die Weihnachtsmärkte und das Oktoberfest aber nicht in einer Weise in die Verantwortung gezogen werden, wie es hier im professionellen Fußball der Fall ist.
Also sprich, die Anschlussfrage, die ich hätte stellen wollen, Lex.DFL, das ist ein klares Ja.
Ja.
Philipp, wie siehst du es? Dammbruch ja oder nein?
Ich würde es auch juristisch jetzt nicht so für einen Dammbruch halten, aber im Ergebnis würde ich genau sagen, was Fabian sagt, was jetzt halt nur nicht passieren dürfte. Und da könnte es ein Dammbruch werden, dass halt Sicherheitspolitiker das als Anlass nehmen, die Debatte weiter zu verschärfen. Und insofern könnte es noch zu einem Dammbruch werden. Das können wir halt noch nicht absehen.
Und Fabian, wieder erste Frage an dich. Wird das die DFL wesentlich verändern, deiner Einschätzung nach?
Was meinst du damit, wird es die DFL verändern?
Also wird sich daran jetzt ein Streit entzünden, der zu neuen Solidargemeinschaftsdefinitionen führt innerhalb der DFL? Oder werden die einfach diese 15 bis 20 Millionen zahlen, die es ja erstmal mutmaßlich sein sollen? Und dann ist es vielleicht dann doch in fünf Jahren, wenn wir zurückblicken, gar nicht das große Thema gewesen.
Na ich denke mal schon, dass sich da ein bisschen was bewegen wird. Oder jedenfalls hoffe ich, dass es der Fall ist. Hängt ja auch so ein bisschen davon ab, ob andere Bundesländer jetzt nachziehen und dem Bremer Beispiel folgen. Und dann sprechen wir natürlich über eine ganz andere Belastung. Und dann muss ich sagen, Tarek Brauer ist da durchaus zuzustimmen. Also dann muss sich da in der DFL quasi eine Solidargemeinschaft bilden. Und dann muss auch RB Leipzig, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt Risikospiele haben, weil die sind zwar nicht so beliebt, aber so richtige Feinschaften mit Fans gibt's da ja glaube ich gar nicht. Dann müssen die eben auch eins sein.
Innerheits-Leipzig glaube ich, aber ansonsten auch.
Aber dann muss sozusagen jeder, der im Übrigen auch zu dieser Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft Liga gehört, der muss dann eben seinen Beitrag dafür leisten. Also das wird schon diskutiert werden, glaube ich.
Philipp?
Auch wieder da. Menno, also kann ich jetzt ohne Weg dazu sagen, es stimmt, bin ich genauso. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es noch weiter ausstrahlt. Denn wenn wir jetzt andere Debatten innerhalb der DFL geführt werden, zum Beispiel um die TV-Rechte und die Mittelverteilung, ist jetzt schon so meine Wahrnehmung, dass man sehr nach dem moral high ground sucht. Also sei es die Argumentation, wir wirtschaften so gut und ihr nicht, wenn wir bestraft oder wir sind team marktwert, daher kam vorhin mein kurzer Einwurf und bei uns ist ja alles viel schöner und viel besser. Da macht man jetzt natürlich, da liefert das Urteil oder sozusagen die Bestätigung, dass diese Kostenfolge grundsätzlich okay ist. Natürlich ein gutes Argument zu sagen, Moment mal, so moral high ground ist das jetzt aber gar nicht. Und vielleicht verschiebt das mittelfristig auch was in dem Bereich. Das wird man sehen müssen.
Und wie glaubt ihr, wird sich das auf Fans, die Spiele besuchen, auswirken, Fabian? Klar ist, dass wir spekulieren müssen, aber es geht ja quasi um dein Gefühl dafür.
Na ja, es kommt jetzt drauf an, von welchem Fan wir sprechen. Meinst du mich beispielsweise?
Du musst zu Hause bleiben.
Ich glaub, auf mich wirkt sich das nicht aus. Also ich hab ehrlich gesagt auch noch bis auf ein einziges Mal noch nie eine unschöne Erfahrung bei Fußballspielen gemacht. Und ich glaub auch ansonsten, wir hatten es ja eingangs schon gesagt, also die, die gewaltbereit sind und sich da unbedingt prügeln wollen, auf die wird es gar keinen Einfluss haben, weil diese von Lage der Nation unterstellte Idee des Fans, ich schad jetzt aber meinem Verein und jetzt auch erst recht, also die gibt es jedenfalls bei denen, die sich die Ärger machen wollen, gibt es das nicht.
Also ich meinte mit Fans jetzt natürlich die Stadionbesucherinnen und Besucher, aber da bist du jetzt ja dann quasi hingekommen. Philipp, hast du ein Gefühl dafür, wie sich das...
Da bleib ich jetzt konsequent von dem, was ich vorher gesagt hab. Ich glaub, da wird sich wenig ändern an der Stelle. Das ist das Einzige, was passieren könnte, dass wir vielleicht jetzt keine Auswärtsfahrten haben an manchen Stellen. So schlimm, wie das sich das anhört.
So schlimm, wie das auch ist. Das ist ja auf EU-Ebene, sprich UEFA mein ich jetzt in dem Fall, ist das ja scheinbar schon akzeptiert, dass es jetzt auch einfach lokale Gesetzgebung geben darf, die dann immer danach durch Gerichte aufgehoben wird. Also sprich Gästefans dürfen nicht anreisen, weil ich verbiet das jetzt einfach. Die bekommen Betretungsverbot für ganze Städte und sieben Monate später sagt ein Gericht, ja, das hättet ihr gar nicht machen dürfen. Und dann ist es aber egal, weil dann ist das Fußballspiel schon mit vorbei. Das ist eine aktuelle Entwicklung, die es zu sehen gibt. Da gibt es Beispiele, die sich immer mehr anhäufen. Also das wird auch zum Beispiel einfach akzeptiert. Hört man auch keine Richterstattung drüber. Ist auch nicht schön, weil da müsstest du auch manchmal für Fans argumentieren, die halt dann vielleicht dann doch keine weißen Kinder sind. Und das ist dann eben einfacher, vielleicht auch gar nicht drüber zu reden oder zu sagen, ja, recht so, dass sie nicht dorthin dürfen. Bleibt noch die Frage, wie gesagt, wir bleiben weiter im Spekulativen. Anders könnte es gar nicht sein. Wie wird sich das auf Polizeitaktikengrund um Fußballspiele ausweiten? Fabian, rechnest du damit, dass das zumindest transparenter wird, was ein Hochrisikospiel ist und was nicht?
Na ja, also das wird wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen davon abhängen, wie der, inwieweit der Rechtsstaat jetzt wieder in Anspruch genommen wird. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Polizei jetzt in ihren Voreinschätzungen da ein bisschen dezidierter sagen wird, wieso und warum sie jetzt der Meinung ist, sie müssten mit dieser Mannstärke auffahren. Aber spätestens dann, wenn es einen Verein gibt oder die DFL gibt, die mal diese Kosten und den Einsatz in Frage stellt und dafür dann vielleicht eben auch den Gerichtsweg bestreitet, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das dann gewisse Effekte hat. Oder im Rahmen solcher Verfahren dann einfach eine Rolle spielt, inwieweit die Polizei da transparent war, was ihre Prognose angeht.
Philipp?
Ja, genau. Das ist, ich meine, wenn es um das Verwaltungsgericht geht, also wenn, das ist ja die erste Frage, ob die DFL sowas überhaupt forcieren würde. Also wenn ich ein Verein wäre und ich kriege diese Kostennote, ja vielen Dank für unsere Leistung berechnen, 24.000 Euro, dann wäre ich am nächsten Tag beim Verwaltungsgericht, weil das muss man tun. Die DFL hätte zumindest genutzt so viel finanziellen Bauchspekt, dass sie es über sich ergehen lassen könnten und regeln es dann intern. Aber wenn es vor Gericht geht, ich meine, es gibt ja keine kleine, keine Verwaltungsverfahren, da gibt es keine Beweislast in diesem Sinne. Aber ich meine, Tatbestandsvoraussetzung muss halt sein. Es ist zu erwartende, also erfahrungsmäßig zu erwartende Gewalthandlung und vorhersehbare Erforderlichkeit. Und das ist dann auch gerichtlich überprüfbar. Aber sagen wir es mal so, es gibt da, wir Kapitalmarkt-Rechner nennen das Informations-Asymmetrien, die Polizei kann halt schon eine Menge begründen, und das meine ich überhaupt nicht böse, kann schon eine Menge begründen, was man halt einfach so hinnehmen müsste, wenn man nicht selbst sehr tief in der Szene drin ist.
Was auch im Zweifel dann nicht aufgedeckt werden muss. Also wenn die Polizei müsste ja zum Beispiel einfach nur sagen, uns liegen Informationen vor, dass Szene XY hier auftauchen will, und deswegen zahlt ihr jetzt bitte den Wasserwerfer. Wie willst du dagegen argumentieren? Und will man überhaupt dagegen argumentieren? Weil eigentlich wollen wir ja, dass die Polizei ihre Aufgabe erfüllt. Es gilt nur, wie in allen Bereichen, in allen Gesellschaftsbereichen, ein gesundes Misstrauen gegenüber allen, denjenigen, die irgendwie ein Gewaltmonopol in irgendeiner Art und Weise innehaben, weil es eben auch zu falschen Entscheidungen, Fehleinschätzungen und manchmal vielleicht auch gelenkten Fehleinschätzungen kommt, um mal so im ganz Wagen zu bleiben. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Ich selbst tue mich auch schwer, zu einem Fazit zu kommen. Ich finde es nur interessant, also ich wusste schon, dass wenn ich mit euch beiden über dieses Thema rede, dass wir anders über dieses Thema reden, als in vielen Teilen der Berichterstattung, die ich gelesen habe. Und gleichzeitig wird das Bild noch komplexer. Ich habe es schon zu Philipp im Vorgespräch gesagt. Je länger man sich damit befasst, desto verworrener wird das Ganze, desto weniger eindeutig sind die Positionen. Ich bewundere diejenigen, die das schaffen, nach so einem Polizeikosten-Urteil dann zu sagen, das ist das Ende des Fußballs oder das ist jetzt ganz, ganz schlimm. Und auch diejenigen, die sagen, das ist absolut exakt so genau richtig ohne Widerspruch. Und hat es endlich mal jemand, den die Hooligans gezeigt. Ich bewundere all diejenigen, die das so sehen können. Ich habe den Eindruck, ganz so einfach ist es nicht, zumindest mir fällt es nicht leicht, da so etwas herauszuziehen aus diesem Urteil. Ich würde euch gerne noch die Möglichkeit geben für letzte Worte, falls es noch irgendetwas gibt, weil ich auch über den juristischen Teil so ein bisschen drüber gehudelt bin. Ehrlich gesagt, das wäre jetzt in keiner Vorlesung von dir durchgegangen, Philipp. Und auch in keinem Liebling Bosmann Podcast wäre das durchgegangen, Fabian. Fabian, du darfst gerne wieder beginnen. Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was dir noch auf der Seele liegt zu diesem Thema?
Also da wir ja noch eine Liebling Bosmann Folge offen haben, wo wir dieses Thema auch besprechen werden, wird dann möglicherweise dein geheimer Wunsch erfüllt, wo wir sozusagen ein bisschen mehr noch in die juristischen Details gehen. Gleichwohl muss ich aber auch sagen, das ist am Ende auch aus meiner Sicht nach wie vor eine politische, gesellschaftliche Frage oder viele, viele Fragen, die sich hier auftun. Und es wäre schön, wenn man es so gelöst bekommen hätte, anstatt hier den Rechtsweg zu gehen. Nur als Jurist weiß ich natürlich auch, dass es manchmal zwanzläufig ist, dass man das macht. Und am Ende eigentlich auch fast immer irgendwas bewegt, wenn man den Rechtsweg geht, insbesondere wenn man ihn zu Ende geht. Weil sich dadurch dann eben neue Türen öffnen, für neue Ideen und vielleicht irgendwie verhärtete Fronten irgendwie nochmal öffnen können. Das wäre meine Hoffnung, weil ich glaube nicht, das hatte ich vorhin schon auch gesagt, dass wir in den nächsten Jahren das Pen-Gewalt-Problem gelöst kommen. Auch nicht mit diesem Urteil.
Ein doch irgendwie positiver Ausblick. Philipp, kannst du da uns draufschlagen?
Wie immer, es ist ja inzwischen eingespielt. Ich hab ja eine Beipflichtung. Und da gibt es juristische Fragen, die zum Beispiel als Anregung, wenn ihr es dann ein bisschen weiter aufdröselt. Ich finde zum Beispiel im Urteil so ganz klar getrennt, also manchmal wird da halt von den Gewinnen und der Profiten und sowas gesprochen, also eher diese monetäre Ansatz. Und dann wird mal wieder von Gefahren und Gewalt und sonst was gesprochen. Ich finde in allen Urteilen geht das manchmal so ein bisschen durcheinander und hier auch. Aber das wird hier wahrscheinlich, da hast du recht Max, ein bisschen sehr zu weit führen. Ich sehe solche Sachen immer ein bisschen als Chance. Vielleicht gibt es mehr Transparenz. Vielleicht setzt sich die DFL da mal ein bisschen zusammen. Aber ich hoffe und ich wiederhole mich damit, dass Politik und Medien das nicht als Ball aufnehmen, um halt noch weiter eine Sicherheitsspirale zu drehen. Ich habe es vorhin begründet. Auf den unmittelbaren Einsatz, glaube ich, wird es wenig, also auf den einen Risikospieleinsatz nicht so viel Einfluss haben, aber insgesamt auf die Tonalität natürlich schon. Weil wenn man es verkürzt, kann man sagen, haha, wir hatten Recht und die Fans nicht. Und das ist nicht gut.
Das ist wirklich nicht gut. Gut war es allerdings mit zwei so tollen Experten sprechen zu dürfen wie euch beiden. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Philipp Maume von der TU München und Fabian Reinholz von der Kanzlei Herting und von Liebling Bossmann. Ich werde natürlich auch verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ich werde generell, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ein paar Links in die Show Notes packen, Quellen, die ich verwendet habe bei der Recherche, weiterführende Artikel. Es wird eine Auswahl sein, denn es gab sehr viel Berichterstattung. Aber ich glaube, wenn euch das Thema interessiert, dann klickt dort oder wartet einfach die paar Tage, bis Liebling Bossmann dann draußen ist dazu. Dann habt ihr nochmal ganz, ganz viele Details. Also herzlichen Dank euch beiden. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern. Denn ihr wisst ja, ihr habt diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-paywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Juli, bei DK, bei Nille Vanille, RBL Glubberer, bei Levan Karm, Magisama, FC Fabian, Blauelilli und bei Lukas1912. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen, haben auf unterstützen geklinkt und uns dann etwas überwiesen, etwas zukommen lassen und sich registriert als Supporterinnen und Supporter. Tut es ihnen gleich für unabhängigen Sportjournalismus, der sich auch ein bisschen Zeit nehmen kann. Es würde mich sehr freuen. Ganz ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gebogen. Bis bald. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.